[Music]
do
fasted
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to round six of the
tata steel chest and run 2022 my name is
fiona style anthony and i'm delighted to
be to be joined for the last time by
grand master robert has robert round six
how are you today
i'm doing great it may be my last day
but it's not for the players they have
so much left to play for yesterday was
another exciting day of chess fiona and
today i think will be even better
absolutely once again we've got plenty
to look forward to but before we go into
the standings let's see what happened
yesterday which i think without a doubt
was the most exciting day of them all
might not look like it when you look at
the results and you see five draws but
there were things happening everywhere
it ended up with only two decisive
results
of beating your then van forest you can
check that it was our
rapid recap of the day so you can find
it on the chess.com youtube channel and
richard report in the longest game of
the day beat pragnanda but robert maybe
you can tell us a few words about the
draws
yeah at some point we thought we could
even get seven decisive results that's
how interesting the games were there
were no quick draws no friendly
handshakes even though good friends in
ishiguri and vita gujarati played i
thought that vida put up great defense
in that one five minute karwana had the
advantage against yesopenko niels
grandilius magus carlson that was a back
and forth affair first niels had the
advantage at least according to the
engine but he said if you say so i
wasn't sure magnus didn't seem so sure
either so a draw on the end was a fair
result
yeah and there we see the standings
after five rounds we have a three-way
tie at the top
uh with mama diaries and reported
catching the early soul leader with
gujarati uh so those are the three men
to catch but in uh
chase in the chasing pack there we see a
certain magnus carlsen uh together with
andreas penko and then just half a point
behind fabiano carrana duda van forest
and well you said it robert such a long
event uh pretty much everyone still has
a chance at at this stage
they certainly do and you never want to
count out magnus carlsen he's only a
half point behind and i believe today
he's got a chance to jump some of the
leaders
indeed as we see those
match-ups and well right there he is
magnus carlson he will be playing
richard report with the white pieces
that's the one to keep an eye on as well
shahid mahmed have another leader he's
playing nils gwandalius who hasn't had
the best start to the event but neil
said in his interview yesterday in a way
it's like the start of a new event after
the rest day so we'll see what he can do
this is another big one with it against
duda and of course uh fabiano
against anish every day we have so much
to look forward here and look forward to
and robert what are the matchups that
you're most excited about
i have to pick just one no i don't match
ups i heard a plural in there and that's
a good thing because of course carlson
versus report in their first game i
think in 2017 if my memory serves me
well report won with the white pieces
against magnus carlson so
report has proven that he can take down
the world champion magnus in this game
has the white pieces he will look to
jump in the score group and then vida
kuzrati white against yan chistop duda
that fiona for me is a really
interesting one because duda had his
chances he was at one point at plus one
score then he lost that game to mama jar
which probably was really heartbreaking
for him so it depends what judas shows
up today the aggressive creative style
that we love to see from the polish
number one or a more solid approach with
the black pieces and i think duda i mean
one can only commend him i i saw that on
on instagram he posted uh something
about the game yesterday against uh
karjakin where in the end suddenly the
engines were jumping up with this crazy
move rook f1 giving a winning advantage
and dude i said something like was i
winning win the end with rook f1 maybe
but uh not so easy to see with two
minutes on the clock and having to find
four uh unique uh four zone moves in a
row so i like his attitude the same as
nils gandelius they were not too phased
by missing a computer line to to win
their game so plenty to look forward to
today robert and as always people at
home can get involved as well
they can indeed they just have to
remember to vote and you get can get
involved by going to chess.com events
and that way you
navigate to the tournament select a game
click vote and then choose your winner
you win a piece of the one thousand
dollar prize pool for best voters or
free diamond memberships voting ends
after the tenth move of each and every
game so do not miss your chance and
remember vote on all the games there's
prize money at sake diamond memberships
you would want a piece of that
and we will be back in just a couple of
minutes here with the start of round six
so don't go anywhere and we'll see you
in a sec
[Music]
welcome back and we're just two minutes
away from the start of round six here we
saw the friendly fist bump between
mamedyarov
and and grand delus
and we see vidit is ready to do better
looking very focused here before the
start of the game robert
yeah and now he's joined by other
co-leaders he had the sole lead for a
couple rounds there and we see sergey
karjakin at his board
at any moment the leaderboard can shake
up and five minute karwana he would love
to get on the scoreboard with a victory
against nishkiri
yeah i think those are two players who
are not completely satisfied with the
start of
their tournament so i'm curious to see
how much risk is each willing to take i
guess anish with the black pieces he
would be more solid there we see the two
russian players daniel duboff against
the sapanga we haven't talked too much
about that game but uh i think this
could also be a a very very interesting
matchup there was a little bit of
discussion uh recently about why did
dubois get the card to play in the grand
prix why didn't they see panko and so
we'll see what happens there
and if yes panko is able to beat duval
with the black pieces you know that will
only stoke the flames so there's
shanklin there's prague
a fist bump shanklin would love to beat
prague not in this game the lowest rated
the youngest player in the field but
program has scored a victory to this
point and shakeland is not and shankland
a lot has been said in the chat about
the bananas he brings to the game i
think the chat is still waiting for the
banana to disappear and we'll see but
for now the game's off we saw a
handshake there between sergey karjakin
and jordan went for race and magnus has
always fashionably late just these few
seconds
and and well we'll see which which move
he opens the game against richard
reports
and for report we'll see if his moves
are bananas b-a-n-a-n-a-s because he
might have saw a surprise in store for
magnus magnus of course has a winning
record against most players including
report he has won two games since that
initial loss so uh with the white pieces
magnus wants to win and ju leapfrog i
would say jump frog i was realizing jump
and leapfrog and merging those words he
would like to leapfrog report in the
standings
and uh well we see that once again we
see this quite often rapport hadn't
cited the clock he had waited four
magnus to arrive and just started the
clock now magnus adjusting all the
pieces carefully before deciding on one
knight of three
yeah he's been choosing knight f3 lately
avoiding any of those pawn pushes in the
center which are more common and we'll
see if report lets him get into a
catalan with eventually g3 bishop g2 you
know d4 c4 we've seen this from magnus
in the world championship we saw it
early in the tournament with his win
against geary and for a report i think
he tends to enjoy avoiding preparation
it's interesting even though it's only
move one rapport looked quite surprised
by knight f3 although magnus he did just
played a few days ago against
helped me help me out robert you're
putting into niche against
yes
yeah so he's been playing it quite
regularly uh in
recent events of the world championship
being the most important amongst them
and for rapport to not have a response
ready is interesting i feel like he's
not coming to the board with that as an
unexpected move but maybe he wasn't
positive which
response he would choose in this game
yeah and
always interesting to see players go
into the tank from move one
uh magnus he played it against the knee
she also played it against jordan
he's been playing it a bunch sometimes i
think the players they are in a spot
where when an open plays an opponent can
play everything sometimes one of the
moves you
rule them out a little bit you think
okay he's already played this tries this
tournament most likely he'll go for
something else so i'm gonna focus maybe
on the other
moves but uh yeah richard well he is now
decided on one d5
maybe he did this intentionally he knew
that the cameras would be on him and he
wanted to steal the show as soon as it
began he said this is
my tournament right now i'm in the lead
so all eyes should be on me but he did
choose d5 magnus quickly responds with
d4 and reports gone from the boards i
don't know what's going on in the early
stages of this game but we're only two
moves in for white one for black and yet
both players are gone
let's bring up the word side view
while we wait for these players to
return
and see what is happening uh elsewhere
well it looks like the game between sam
and pregnant they have been moving fast
uh what is happening in the other games
robert where it's still very early doors
yeah my attention was on that game as
well i saw queen on b4 knight on b5 i
know exactly what opening that came from
it was the sicilian it was an influence
of magnus carlsen and fabiana carwana
and many other players of course as well
but that's that world championship
impact when players played in the
biggest event in the world you start
seeing it from all the other players and
what interesting game that will be in
the bottom right i see fabiano that is
really interesting to me
fiona he has fianchettoed both bishops
it's not like there's too much going on
right now but in the bottom left hand
side of the screen on that board there
fabiano fianchettoing both bishops who
has inspired him
well uh
i'm curious i think we've seen magnus
we've seen kramnik when he was selective
but from korea uh curry run
i tried to mix karana and fabiano i
think there but yeah it's not an opening
we have seen him play too much before
no but i mean i think we have to
really look across here mama jarov
calm start to his game against nils and
we see vidit and duda there in e four so
it's from a semitarash judah continues
to play that variation he did that
earlier in the tournament against prague
so fiona where should we
look at first i'm guessing you're gonna
say do ball against yes panko really
exciting position but besides that one
which catches your eye
i mean it's interesting that both yes
the penguin reports sort of went into
the tank
but yes panko is taking it to the to the
next level here will we'll leave him to
it maybe we can start with sam shankland
and pregnant
for sure i have that position up ready
and sam shanklin came ready for this
game today because we're 13 moves in and
now it's pregnant on the move so if we
go back to the start here
it was a sicilian
the knight comes to c6 again
fabio under car one of the white pieces
magnus carlos and the black pieces we
saw this game after game in the 2018
world chess championship this was not
the first time this opening wasn't
played but it had such an impact where
it wasn't the most popular choice at the
highest levels but when magnus carlsen
does something people follow it's kind
of like that mean girls effect you know
fiona
very true and we talked about i think
the influence when magnus plays
something in general but especially when
it's a world uh championship match
right because all those months of
preparation that went into it you know
that it's a sound opening that there's a
lot to it and d4 choosing the open
variation rather than bishop to b5 which
keep things a little more close so we
said d4 takes takes knight f6 attacking
the pawn knight c3 defending and then e5
so fiona this choice this opening here i
think for some it may look a bit
weakening right because you push upon
you if it's backwards deep on but we
know that this is quite common theory
yeah all of this has been uh analyzed so
deeply while we see the knight jump into
b5 and again i think a lot of players
when they start out and not just that
even club players or
they wonder what's going on here why do
i allow all these weaknesses under dark
square d6
is kind of weak then there's this
outpost on on d5 as well
but all of this has been analyzed so
deeply and in fact it's turned out that
this is all rock solid for for black
that's right and d6 is an important
first move because you did not want the
knight to jump in there now the queen
joins the bishop in defense knight to d5
very clear so this move fiona it
threatens knight to c7 check that much
is clear but it also forces black to
change the pawn structure after knight
takes d5 e takes d5 and i think i know
your answer but i'm going to ask the
question anyway when you see this change
in pawn structure do you prefer it from
the black side or the white side
i think i prefer it from the the white
side um
i in general i i see this pawn on d6 in
my mind i think that can be a long-term
weakness i also think maybe i can get my
bishop out castle and at some point
throw my f on up the board but in
general i like that the pawn on on d5
which is going to be uh solidified well
not solidified but strengthened by a c4
push which actually was white's uh next
move so i like white here but what about
you
i i agree although you also have to
appreciate that black can get some play
on the king side in the center because
if we cut the board in half which you
know i like to do i wish i could draw a
line right down the middle chess.com if
you're listening let's get that as a
feature please because i have to do
through the the file i would like to go
right in between the king and queen and
cut the board in half and the point is
that black has an extra pawn from the e
through h file so when you play f5 you
have two pawns here in the center and
white plays on the queen side we have c
and d pawn so only a d-pawn so white
would like to eventually start pushing
these pawns we see in the game queen a4
bishop d7 queen b4 hitting the d6 pawn
black does not want to part with the
bishop hair plays queen to b8 all of
this has been played before h4 trying to
play h5 and kick this knight out and
black plays h5 white plays bishop e2
black now kicks the knight and knight c3
so fiona this is where the game has led
us and at this moment
i was about to say the h5 pawn is under
attack black goes for the h4 pawn but it
seems that white can protect the pawn
whereas black has a bit more difficult
time protecting h5 because the knight is
on g6 and well we see sam has already
gone g3 he has he is up almost six
minutes from his starting time so he
really hasn't used even uh a few seconds
and just been playing everything
instantly and yeah the question is
indeed for
like oh robert you're wishes
that's awesome see that actually makes
it much clearer right you see the line
splitting the board in half and black
has that extra pawn on e5 on that side
of the board and then white has the c4
pawn so i really like that thank you
very much
that does look great we can keep the
line there man i'm sure it'll come in
handy not keep there but i mean keep it
in our back pocket and it'll come in
handy again later on i'm sure
um and yeah so g3 defending the pawn on
h4
and the question for black how is he
going to deal with the h5 pawn in the
long term also the question that i'm
always curious about is uh where do the
kings go and here i'm curious for both
sides are those kings going to castle
kingside
would they be going queenside are they
going to stay in the
middle of the board what's what's
happening with that
before i answer your question which is
good when i'm partially buying myself
time but i think this is important when
you're playing someone like sam shanklin
who is renowned for his opening
preparation
i'm now wondering if this was a bad idea
from pragnanda he's thinking it's move
15 he has plenty of time left to reach
the time control
but sam he is among the most if not the
most deeply prepared players in the
world so where 15 moves in sam not even
thinking he's using his pre-game work
and he's applying at the board here and
if i'm not mistaken the move f5
is an option at this point and there's
also the move b5 and
b5 that involves a pawn sacrifice at
least temporarily because knight pawn
queen bishop all stare at this b5 square
and f5 if i'm remembered correctly was a
choice in the game jordan von forrest
against magnus carlson in vikings a
several years back so f5 that it makes
perfect sense because you have an extra
pawn as we keep mentioning from the e to
the h files you start pushing your pawns
up but whenever you push upon your king
that may make your king more vulnerable
yeah so
a lot of double-edged decisions here on
the horizon pregnant end up very likely
he is also familiar uh with this
position but so often you you uh you
don't know of course which line is going
to appear at the board so he might not
have looked at this as recently as sam
has and he goes for for b5
he does it's a pawn sacrifice so c takes
b5 a takes b5 this knight can come and
take on b5 and the reason why this is a
decent pawn sacrifice sorry i didn't
mean to undo my moves here the reason
why this is a decent sacrifice is the
queen on b8 pins the knight on b5 and
black still is going to operate in the
center and on the king side an eventual
f5 maybe even e4 bring this knight into
this e5 square so we can see the type of
activity that black can get in a
position like this and honestly it is a
really ambitious choice from pragananda
and perhaps my knowledge of sam shanklin
and just how quickly he's played against
me in the past i have some trauma from
it where he has spent no time for the
entire game and
and i have remember when he had the
white pieces he was the black and he
made the easiest draw of all time and he
had more time than he started with by
the end of the game so we'll see sam i
mean he knows what's up he continues to
play quickly but pragmata also within
his preparation because you don't play
the move b5 that quickly if you haven't
seen the position before
and by the way this is a complete aside
but i saw some discussions in the chat
some people being worried that prague
wearing a mask might be to his
disadvantage so just to let everyone
know the players don't have to uh it is
their choice i believe pregnant
uh always wears a mask also in previous
events so it is up to
up to the players and robert let's go
back to the bird's eye view this one
shaping up to be a very exciting
game for now we're still in the the
opening preparation battle
but what's going on elsewhere
well damil dubov in the top right
against andreas panko that's a very
well-known catalan line i see that in
the game between magnus and report the
magnus is down a pawn and you see some
similarities you look at top left and
top right
both sides have these fianchetto bishops
bishops on g2 but the difference is in
how black approached the position
because right now magnus is down a pawn
and
daniel is not but black missing a d5
pawn in both the boards so it's kind of
interesting to see how players can
choose and this is a good visual example
i'm also quite curious about the
karjakin against the jordan fence for
race game which seems to have come
from an italian but very rare to see
a knight landing on b5 so early we'll
check in there of course
as well
but robert i'll let you choose where
where do we start
well i'm now i'm looking at the cardiac
and von forest position and there's a
bishop on b8 which is the worst piece in
the round so that wins the award for
worst piece of the round um that bishop
is not happy to be there the knight
kicked it back there and interesting to
see
von forrest who is a very
strong player obviously he won last year
but he has come up with so many creative
ideas in the opening so maybe just
quickly because i don't think at the
moment the game isn't going to open up
and become too lively but there's a
bishop on b8 and it is not a good piece
i mean it's very unusual that's what had
caught my eye about this game as well
very unusual in the italian
to see the night maybe we can see
if we quickly go from the beginning
so it was just a typical joko piano
until now nothing out of the ordinary a5
rookie one bishop a7 all normal until
now but then again this knight a3 move
which we saw
um played not in this exact position but
a few days ago in general it's more
usual to see the knight develop via d2
and f1 and activate somewhere
in the center than after via g3 or e3
knight a3
and
i don't recall seeing a position like
this before robert
i i kind of like it though because uh in
this game he brings the knight to b5
quickly and he's taking advantage of the
fact that black pushed the pawn to a5 or
pawns move up they can't move backwards
that's just how chess works sorry
everybody so the palm would like to be
able to go to a6 and kick the knight but
in this position we see that that's
unavailable and if bishop b6 were played
he chose bishop b8 for a reason and
perhaps he didn't want an exchange of
the dark square bishops then eventual
bishop e3 i don't know why one would be
fearful of it but i do trust jordan and
his preparation and bishop b8 indicates
to me that he is going to move his
knight at some point and play c6 and
then open up the bishop on this diagonal
but at first glance i mean i really like
the way this position looks for white
fiona black is solid protects this pawn
on c7 which is really important because
in d takes e5 in this kind of territory
there's no concern about this pawn
because that sad looking bishop is at
least doing one job
yeah and well we see that jordan hasn't
spent any time so clearly this is
something he didn't fall into this i
think if we didn't have the the clock
situation we might think
that you didn't mix up some lines here
why is that bishop on v8 but
it looks like this was his plan and i'm
i'm curious to see how how this game
develops
yeah like i said bishop on b8 i mean
not a happy piece but black is going to
go forward with a typical plan probably
bring a rook to e8
try to complete the development this
bishop on c8 can get out of there but it
seems very cramped for black and at some
point perhaps there's going to be a move
like knight a7 as well to kick the
knight out of b5 but it does have the
feel of a position that you'd much
prefer to have from the white side but
karjakin is the one thinking
yeah and we'll see what he can cook up
uh we'll see
how jordan is planning to deal with that
bishop from v8 but it's not the first
time that jordan has shown some some
deep ideas that uh
this reminds me a little bit almost of
the pawn sacrifice in his game against
magnus where it wasn't clear at first
but then the ideas came to the forefront
later so we'll see what happens here for
now
let's go back for a second to the the
bird's eye
view
and maybe robert we can check in briefly
with one of our co-leaders well with uh
with witted gujarati and young shish of
duda i wanted to go there while the
queens are still on the board which i
hope i hope they will remain
queen trade offered i don't mind the end
game it seems like yanchez of duda does
not mind the end game either he has just
played queen to c7 if this position
looks familiar it's because duda against
pragnanda followed a similar path and
not exactly
to this point because the queen's on f4
and queen jared is offered but out of
the opening
here in this uh
first queen's gambit declined then c5 we
get this
semitash
opening where you trade off a bunch of
pieces and it looks like a grunfeld
fiona but there's no pawn on g6 bishop
on g7 so the dark square bishops come
off the board
yeah so what is the compensation here
for black let's say for widespread pond
center
yeah it's the long term and exactly what
duda is doing is what's principled here
so if we just continue to the game line
i know we're rushing through some of the
opening a bit but this is
well trodden paths at this point and he
puts his rook on c8 so he has this open
file to work with whereas white has put
the rooks in the center behind
pawns that will likely push at some
point so after bishop b3 rook e8 this is
a strange looking move but it
anticipates a move like d5 getting ready
for that pawn break the rook on f8 not
doing much they're working at least not
preventing an option but making that
option have some repercussions with the
rook trying to use an open line and
after h3 knight f6 the pawn e4 is under
attack so i think this is a clear
answer to your question by the position
black has applied pressure in the center
has a rook on an open file has the extra
pawn on the a and b file so if we get to
an end game that will be to black's
advantage because when you have pawns in
the center you restrict pieces the fewer
pieces that remain the fewer pieces that
can be restricted and thus after queen
f4 queen c7 you're offering that queen
trade the pawn on e4 will be a target if
the queens trade you you really don't
want to make the move e5 and hand block
the d5 square and open up the diagonal
for the bishop so i think that both
sides are doing things absolutely
perfectly thus far and now if i'm fitted
i'm avoiding the queen trade to the move
like knight e5 i guess queen h4 also
comes to mind but i really really really
do not want to trade those queens i like
knight e5 um robert tell me if i'm being
too too optimistic after 95 can i dream
about applying some pressure on f7 in
the long term or is that never going to
happen
i don't think it's that big of a dream
your bishop is on a good square at some
point the position will likely open up
and black needs to be very careful
because if d5 happens
and we see a trait of pawns here let's
just throw a random move on h6 which is
not a move you just play offhandedly but
like let's say we get some situation
here
you're trying to get d6 to work and use
this diagonal to your advantage so
black needs to be careful in these
positions you'd have to blockade with
queen to d6 you cannot afford to allow
that pawn to push and queens are
notoriously bad block haters but only if
you can attack them and the reason why
they're bad block haters is as soon as a
queen's attack it has to move
unfortunately for white in a bit of a
tangle so you're not gonna have time to
just kick that queen out of there so an
interesting decision here i think
almost already the first critical moment
of the game for
a vidit where he decides
how
is the course of the game going to look
like for the next while either queen's
gonna stay on am i gonna play knight e5
and uh yeah i would see him there
looking to the side and he's the one
actually who has spent uh quite a bit of
well not quite a bit of time but ten
minutes while duda has played everything
instantly up five minutes on the clock
dude is in his comfort zone he knows
these positions very intimately and for
fit it we saw him play g5 and h5
yesterday that's part of the plan in
this position from white's perspective
you asked about the f7 square sometimes
white starts throwing these pawns up the
board and tries to go for g5 to remove
this knight from f6 and it was what i
was dreaming of but i didn't even air
and they're asking you can i go to e45
there are no such thing as bad
suggestions when you're not the ones
making the moves because that's how you
come up with good ideas like sometimes
you make a move it's a huge blunder but
you keep that idea in your back pocket
you know wait i'm trying to make it work
and actually g4
in these positions can be a good choice
because the knight on f6 does not want
to move we could show in this position
that knight d7 is a huge blunder because
the f7 pawn so that's the point of
playing g4 and trying to play g5 is that
the knight would have to go to the rim
and it can't go to d7 unless you protect
the f7 pawn so these positions are
really interesting i have not studied
them that deeply but i've commented a
bunch of games i've mentioned wesley so
linear dominguez they've had battles in
lines either exactly like this position
or a similar but with it some different
moves played to this point but either
way this g4 push has to be considered
once we put the 95
an interesting battle on the horizon for
sure let's go back
again see what's happening elsewhere and
maybe we should go back to world
champion
magnus carlson
we saw that richard report had left the
board after the first move and but
a few things have happened here we did
transpose to catalan and uh well let's
take a closer look
sorry my eyes also we're on that shank
them game against prague that one's
really interesting but we will stay here
for now the carlson game against report
where only seven moves in and report has
done quite a lot of thinking
so we saw d5 d4 was the immediate
response from magnus and then knight f6
so c4 e6 this is all normal good stuff
and here at g3 the start of the catalan
and
report says i'm not scared i'm going to
take your opponent c4 and we get this
dynamic phenomena that we've seen so
many times in recent high level chess
and of course vladimir kramnik played
the catalan for a long time and he wrote
a book about it
but the bishop on g2 has an open
diagonal to work with but report shows
one of those lines where he's trying to
keep his extra pawn
yeah so
he started with knight c6
and after castles got his work to beat
so out of that long
diagonal meaning that in the long term
it might be easier to to play a move
like b5 to try and hold on to the pawn
of course you have to be very careful
because b5 removes the defender of the
knight on c6 so that's something to look
out for but he is making preparations
for
getting his pieces out of that long
diagonal
and look at this move by magnus bishop
to e3 if you
showed
somebody this game and they saw the
bishop 23 like what is that bishop doing
there this is not a novelty it has been
played before
at this point the move knight c3 is more
popular the line continues knight c3
black plays his move a6 i think it's
clear that black wants to play the move
b5
there's e4 from white i think black
refrains from playing b5 for the time
being first plays bishop e7 the pawn's
not under attack and only after the move
queen e2 does black play b5 so these
kinds of positions are extremely sharp
white plays rook d1 you have these pawns
in the center that can start moving up
the board and i mean if
this might be the peace sacrifice line
like i know i'm getting really deep into
the weeds so some people that what are
you doing others might appreciate it but
there are positions where white goes d5
and then plays e5 hoping that this
knight moves so you can just take this
pawn on d5 with the rook staring down
against the queen and then black plays
d4 white takes on f6 black takes back
and look at this position fiona three
pawns for the sacrifice piece this is
such a complex position it has been very
well
studied researched and you know we need
that one d4 course borisov rook to come
and save us
yeah very wild stuff but magnus saying
none of that
today i'm not interested instead bishop
e3 which at first sight looks like such
a weird move hard to explain once again
uh when when we develop our bishops in
general we put them on f4 maybe on g5
but very rarely do we put them in front
of a a non
non-pushed e4 pawn
right because that's
what's advantage having given up a pawn
is to have those pawns in the center
bishop e3 does have the benefit of
protecting this d4 pawn which can free
up the queen to go to a square like c2
and not drop this pawn to the center and
from reports point of view if he says i
want to attack this bishop it's you know
close to me knight d5 the bishop will
move but if you move the knight from f6
then e4 becomes easier to play so for
example knight d5 bishop b2 you've
allowed me to play e4 with a tempo
against your knight so you don't want to
just chase a bishop just because you can
and instead i would consider developing
my dark square bishop playing a move
like a6 to prepare b5
you could ask why prepare b5 then i put
my rook on b8 to do just that then we
see why this bishop is on e3 look at
this a7 pawn over here
it's
sort of
hidden and under attack because of the
bishop but after b5 there's a move
knight to e5 available or a4 first but
after knight e5 if you decide to take
now your pawn on a7 is in some danger so
these lines can be really interesting
and sharp and the bishop on e3 you see
is clear purpose in a variation like
this aiming at that pawn on a7 yeah a
very interesting setup chosen by magnus
carlsen and he clearly has taken richard
to report by surprise
who's spending quite a bit of time here
in the opening
robert shall we update the shankland
game and then we'll take our first quick
break of the day
for sure i'll pull that up right now uh
we see that shanklin and pragananda
they're deep into this game it's already
moved 21. there's a bishop on g6 and
look at sam's clutch time
yeah i mean look this is
i i said it as like a friendly piece of
advice and in general would avoid going
into
deep theory against sam shanklin however
prognonda didn't get here by accident he
has looked at this line if this queen is
able to slide over here checkmate
is going to be a problem for black to
deal with there's no h pawn and if we
just go back a few moves
b5 was played we saw this the knight
took castles a4 protecting this knight
on b5 some more though the rook is not
defended on a1 which is why after f5
bishop takes h5
bishop takes b5 you cannot take back
on b5 the rook is not defended so if you
take with the queen
this is
fairly straightforward the rook down on
a1 is loose and black would take the
game so instead
sam takes his knight on g6 the bishop
goes to d8 threatening bishop a5 and
here sam already has made his move queen
to b3 avoiding the pin of his queen
trying to go queen f3 queen h5 and fiona
i'm scared for both players yeah i mean
i'm just looking at this position
thinking what is going on this position
is completely wild
but once again the engine is not faced
the engine says zero zero
which always makes me think
what is it here is there some way for
this to just
um
you know uh
come to to draw somewhere i'm also
concerned i am very concerned for the
black king i'm also somewhat concerned
for the white king on e1 especially with
the bishop on b5 which is cutting off
the diagonal so we could i could picture
a bishop coming to a5 and i'm not sure
what the white king is doing either so
yeah
wild wild stuff here
it's
it's just such a fascinating position
and they're still following a a game
that has been played between uh arjun
kalyan and velamir ivic from the
grand swiss in riga so
i believe it was that was determined in
riga so i assume the grand swiss from
2021 but look at this position the
players have studied it other
grandmasters have played it fiona it
needs some serious analysis before
venturing into this kind of game
absolutely well and we'll see pregnant
has he analyzed that deeply enough if so
does he remember on the lines it's him
to move and we'll come back to this game
as well as to all the others after a
short break so don't go anywhere and
we'll be right back
[Music]
so
yeah i grew up analyzing with the board
but things are very different now most
of the analysis is done on on the
computer
most of the time i work
with computer with engines ai and its
legacy will be answered in
the future the engines are so much
stronger than humans that you tend to
believe
what they say change the game the way we
see the game
very differently i sometimes think over
the board and try to you know find human
ideas and also use computer as well
i think i'm more scared in terms of the
future of trust of computers just
processing faster and then if they
become a little bit stronger i worry
that one day chess can be weakly solved
if i don't use technology i'll be just
lagging behind
against all my colleagues because you
have to use it kind of luckily i still
think that day is very very far away and
i think it will be after i'm retired
many many years in the future
solving chess is way way out there and
frankly i hope that it won't be
in a very very long time ai generally
brought new ideas and a lot of things
maybe people would have discovered
eventually but just made it much much
quicker we want to
learn from the best and currently the
best is
simply the machines not the humans yeah
we lost this battle
[Music]
welcome back and really interesting to
hear the players thoughts on how they
use technology and the progress of
artificial intelligence
we also have here in vicanza in just 50
minutes the game changer
conference starting
you can all watch this
live it will be broadcast to youtube
there will be two experts in the field
of ai as well as women international
master natasha ragan from england she
co-authored the game changer book
alongside matthew sadler and the final
participant is none other than
grandmaster peter heiner nielsen who is
the main coach of magnus carlsen among
other things but also very invested and
interested in all these topics relating
to ai in chess
well i think what you meant fiona is
that they can watch that later on you
know youtube on their own time because
they'll be busy watching the action of
these seven games that they see on the
screen in front of you that's exactly
what i meant uh you could go back
tonight and watch the event on youtube
we'll leave the link in the chat i
believe um but yeah don't go now check
it out later
and uh robert we are back in the bird's
eye view
um what is catching your attention
how could we not pay attention to the
shank clinton versus prague not the game
i know we were just there we were
talking about it the first novelty was
played by shanklin on move 21 so i think
just quickly can we uh look at this then
we'll switch any other game that you
want of course
yeah the first new move was queen to b3
in the
predecessor game between uh kalyan and
ivic bishop d2 was played stopping
bishop a5 from winning the queen so that
this is the first new choice trying to
potentially get pregnant in unfamiliar
territory but he responds to bishop a5
check the king cannot move because king
d1 is meant by bishop to e2 check and
your queen is under threat you see the
evaluation bar go very uh in black's
favor because after this rook c8 is yeah
rookie check the king has to move you
lose your queen that's just the end of
the game so that's why sam responded
with bishop to d2
prog now that took it and if k takes d2
this bishop is under attack
but that doesn't mean you have to move
it i think when our pieces are
threatened we feel like we have to do
something about it but this king is in
the open so i was looking at the move
queen a7 as a way of attacking the f2
pawn it looks really
scary for
that king on d2 and
now i think you have to deal with that
threat because if you take on b5 with
the queen
in comes one of these rooks maybe this
rook to b8 b2 is hanging f2 is hanging
and throwing in this rook b8 move fiona
i think it may not come naturally to
most players but if you get hungry for
this pawn f2 right away the queen can
block so i wanted to attack from every
which way yeah and rook v8 makes sense
because the white queen cannot defend
both the pawn on f2 and the pawn on b2
so those pawns uh the pawn on f2 isn't
going anywhere and yeah this would just
be completely winning
for
for black i had the one question in the
position in the game does it make a
difference i like your move queen a
seven looking down at f2 does it make a
difference whether we go to a7 or b6
it's a very good question i didn't want
to stay in the pin any longer than i had
to uh so i was wondering if white
protected this pawn on f2 would there be
something and another big difference is
after queen takes b5 you don't have rook
b8 first so you get queen takes f2 check
and if the king moves then you will get
rook to b8 but the queen can drop back
here and i have to admit haven't
calculated this all the way through
there may be some kind of repetition i
see the eval bars at zeros um but if we
just try to queen d4 check and keep
checking the king we see the bar go up
because you're running out of checks
quite quickly so maybe there's a way
forward where black scoops up g3 and
then gets checked in the future queen f4
trying to come over here look to b8
still as an option the bishop's under
attack and it seems that there's a
dynamic equality would you be very
careful in positions like this but of
course why not play queen a7 which is
what prague has done and keep the extra
option
of rook b8
uh alive and well queen a7 is on the
board sam has been playing incredibly
fast but i guess already here
in this kind of position when we see
zero zeros
we tend to be more concerned that there
might just be a perpetual on the horizon
sam certainly is looking for more and
was looking for more with his prep but
how does he deal with the the threat of
queen f2 check
and i thought that shanklin was the
person whose preparation you should be
afraid of now i'm going to just have the
utmost respect for pragnanz preparation
he's a young player he's studying hard
and we're 23 moves deep and he clearly
knows exactly what to do so how does he
deal with this threat if you take on b5
you're in trouble queen e3 trying to
trick queens makes sense to me because
white is up a pawn but first of all we
can trade queens and take a4 i think we
can also try to continue the attack with
queen a5 check
and if the queen comes to c3 we probably
drop back to a7
and this might be one of those
awkward draws by repetition of the
queens going back and forth and avoiding
the trades
i think uh well i'm not figuring out
that we could see this draw here and i
think
you have talked plenty we've talked
plenty about how we wish uh we didn't
have drawfish but i think here once
again it's it's a different story
because this just happens in just
sometimes sam clearly was super well
prepared i had some fresh ideas queen b2
b3 was a novelty and sometimes
it just happens that in these lines if
your opponent knows everything in the
end it's just gonna be a draw
and when he knows everything it looks
like oh why didn't you try something
else is right but that doesn't tell the
whole story if prague hadn't found the
most precise moves i've ever turned or
known them either known them or found
them and it could be a crushing uh
victory for white so i think these
things just happen robert
it's part of the game preparation all
the hard work that goes in before the
game even begins that's a part of chess
and it is in fact a skill to be able to
work that hard to find these variations
because this is not like a popular line
at this point they've deviated from
that earlier in the game and now they
both know it they both studied very hard
and if they draw the game they draw the
game which would be a victory in a sense
for progananda the black pieces against
a strong player that's a great result to
draw without too much of a sweat
indeed and well we'll see if
if sam does go for queen e3
not so clear to see what else he he
could do but we'll keep an eye on this
and well let's bring back the bird's eye
view and i'm
i'm gonna pick a game we haven't looked
at at all and i believe uh karana
against anish we talked about the double
fiance but we haven't looked at it in
detail so let's let's go there
it reminds me of my online blitz games
and that's not a good thing i promise
you you know you don't want to be in
those kinds of positions but this is how
i play in online blitz and if we see how
we got here it's
simply fianchettoing both bishops and
i'm fascinated to know why fabiano chose
this to me it seems like a sign of
frustration anisha is a very well
prepared player these two have played
each other i think something like 35
times they have an even record in their
head-to-head matchups and classical
chess and so fabiano are trying to take
anish out of his preparation and look at
the clocks by the way fiona i'm just
noticing that fabian has more time than
he started with as we continue to get to
the game position and anish is the one
burning clock i hadn't noticed that
either and it just tells you that
sometimes
even these positions if we look at the
black position all the moves
seem to come
natural to black and you might be
wondering why has a niche
spent over half an hour to get to this
but first of all it is absolutely clear
he did not expect fabiano to go for this
line and second of all i think there's
just
so many ways in which you can set up and
with every little white move you have to
think okay what is a fabiano what does
he want to do next how do i best prepare
against it so it's not uh as obvious as
it looks
not at all and he drops the bishop to h7
e4 played anyway the knight came to d7
queen to e2 queen to b6 and only now
does white play a4 and the thing about
this position is people will be tempted
to play a4 as black you want a5 why did
you do that probably to play a4 but then
white pushes through to b4 and you see
the evaluation will start to creep up
because this pawn a4 will be a long-term
issue for black to defend and white just
gained important space so you don't want
to push a4 often when white establishes
the pawns here because the pawn a4 is
going to be a target later the bishop on
b2 really strong slicing to the position
and
white has a bit more space that's why
queen b6 was the choice and then fabiano
played a4
part of the reason why
why choose a4 now is that this bishop on
b2 is a bit loose and if you get a4 and
c5 and all these types of moves in that
can be annoying for white here on the
queen side so a4 shuts down black's play
and then a niche for the move rook f to
see it's a fiona
i think we often think our rooks need to
go in the center maybe you can explain
why the f rook decided to come over here
to see it yeah i think well it's a great
question
it looks i think a lot of players would
be tempted to move the a-rook and then
move the rook from f
from the f-file to d8 or to e8 but i
guess it indicates that anish is
preparing to get some play under the
queen side maybe try and push at the b
pawn or the c pawn and the rook on a8
although it isn't doing much it is
supporting uh the b pawn it is defending
it and
i think we will see those pawns start
advancing and that's why the rooks here
and each determined are well placed on
a8 and d8
yeah when there have been precisely zero
trades
trying to figure out where your rooks
belong is not always easy because no
matter which file it went to it's
sitting behind a pawn but your idea with
b5 makes perfect sense that queen can
slide back and then you can play b5 and
you'll need this rook on a behind the a5
pawn or as you mentioned the rook can
come to the b file and try to support b5
in some universe there may be c5 c4 not
in this game playing with c5 will be a
very bad choice let's say i make this
with h3 a comm move and you say oh i'm
going to put my rook on c8 i have to
push my c pawn after pawn takes d5 your
bishop is loose on e7 in these positions
in many of them and if you take with the
knight on d5 you give me the c4 square
and you have all these
holes for black on the light squares and
white has great control with this bishop
still very strong and like coming to e5
white's pieces are just better
yeah so uh absolutely anish he will be
looking for a pawn break but you have to
be
very careful especially it's interesting
that anish he didn't choose to fiancatu
any of his bishops in response to
fabiano's double fiance so right now the
two bishops are unopposed on their
respective diagonals which means you
have to be even more careful when making
a pawn pressure
and the good thing for black about the
current pawn structure this triangle
pawn structure limits this bishop on g2
and the bishop on h7 is also living in
scope so white has the best minor piece
on the board for the time being the
bishop on b2 has the most access
compared to the others but
where to go from here i mean even a move
for white at this moment isn't that easy
to spot
and for black you're so solid and if
white's trying to crash through like
move like e5 would need to be played but
then you release the tension in the
position so after the knight retreats to
e8 that's the only place it can go to
now black has some options because c5
can be played without the tension on d5
and the capture or the queen will move
say to c7 or d8 and the palm will go to
b5 and that's how black needs to strike
in a position like this especially if
white is just trying to take space on
the king side and maybe push some pawns
and try to attack
yeah so this one uh it's almost a little
bit like a just 960 game in the sense
that this game hasn't been so much about
opening preparation or theoretical
knowledge and i'm really enjoying seeing
the players just
figuring things out more or less step by
step here in this position
right so
fabiano he's finally going to start
using some of his time and then he'll
come up with a plan not easy to figure
out what plan that will be but we still
have many other interesting games that
are in some tense moments yeah so let's
bring back the overview
um
well my eye is going to vet it i'm happy
to see the queen's eye still on the
board he did go for knight e5
uh and my eye is also going to my media
off against grand delus
where i see the e file has opened white
has just gotten castle maybe we can
check in there since i think we haven't
haven't looked at at that game yet
we have not and it's been the day of
knight f3 so that's the first move by
mama jarv by caruana by carlson and
niels plays c5 so if mama jarv was in
the mood he could have played a sicilian
he could put e4 and then we'd get a
sicilian
he says no that's not my style today
excuse me
he plays c4 instead we get a symmetrical
english knight c3 knight f6 and e3 so
white is first to the punch in the
center here and supports the d4 square
by a pawn e3 and then fiona we see the
move a6 so how do we justify when white
is playing in the center and black is
playing on the flank
yeah i think a6 another move which has
come into fashion lately which is not
easy to to explain because why
is black doing that um i think very
often it is linked first of all taking
away uh the square b5 also some
potential uh b5 purchase in the future
um niels actually he has uh
made a course i believe on chesapeal on
the the a6 not in the english but in the
the queen's
gambit the queen's gambit declined which
he called the
magnus uh a6 line or the magnus queens
gambit so once again we see the
influence um even if it's not not this
position exactly of of magnus here
it seems to go against all the rules
your coach tells you you develop your
pieces you play in the center and then
you see grandmaster niels grandilius
play a6
but but coach niels did that so i want
to do it too there is a clear purpose to
move a6 it's what fiona was talking
about taking away the b5 square because
he anticipated d4 happening and after
the swap of pawns plays d5 and now it's
really important that the b5 square is
under black's control because in many
positions you'd like to put a bishop on
the b5 square here i'd be tempted to
make the move c5 precisely because the
pawn is on a6 and then i'm going to try
to take over the b6 square because
there's no pawn to hold on to it but
then you have to worry about moves like
bishop g4 and white's center can
collapse at any moment if you're not
careful with black removing some of the
guards so it's not like white just has a
free hand here and after d5 we saw
bishop g5
bishop e6 to defend the pawn again an
odd move with the bishop in front of the
king pawn but the move e6
which is a reasonable choice it allows
white to
um say i i'm a leading development i
have three minor pieces out you only
have two and then you can say that this
a6 move isn't as helpful to the position
you would rather have had your bishop on
e7
yeah and i think bishop e6 also well now
it sort of brings back my other point of
in some lines you might want to take on
on c4
and then you are ready to hold try and
hold on to that pawn by playing b5
that's right and the bishop on e6 it's
attacking the c4 square and mama jeff
says please go ahead take it because you
lose a piece in this particular position
but as we continue to say it's not about
this current move just keep the idea
open that black can take that pawn on c4
it would lose a piece for now but later
it may come in handy so in this game g6
was played bishop takes politics and
castle so it's an interesting dynamic
fiona where there's double f pawns for
black the king is still in the center
but black is holding on for dear life on
this d5 square and not allowing white to
break through
so what is the the plan for nils the
bishop will it go to g7 which looks like
the natural square after g6 has been
played
um
and
i wonder after that do we want to play
f5 to open up
uh the bishop or are we worried about
creating some holes what what do you
think that the plans are for black
black has to be okay with white taking
on d5 at some point because you are
holding down the center as it is so yeah
for white i would think about playing
the move c5 i'm still nervous about my
pawn on d4 so it's a consideration not
something i would do without some
serious thought because as soon as you
play c5 and you see the evaluation we're
actually starting to slip down
there's no longer the opportunity to
take on d5 which means that black is
very safe here in the center and then
can focus his attention on the d4 pawn
so
it's
the keeping the tension prevents black
from certain options so i'd probably
just make a move like queen d2
especially now that i saw that c5 is in
that inaccuracy and then if blackberry
castle
i will continue in the center because at
some moment i may want to take on d5 i
don't want to rush that decision because
if we get here
black is better and the reason why is
this d4 pawn and as you point out f5
rook d8 it's clear that there's too much
pressure piling up against this pawn and
the bishop on g7 once it opens up will
be such a great piece and an interesting
positional struggle here between these
two players i will come back here
let's see is there anything else we
haven't looked at yet maybe we haven't
looked at the russian clutch between
duboff
and yes it panko and i'm just having a
quick look to
make sure we're not missing what i'm
seeing is sam is still thinking
after queen a7 i can imagine that sam is
not too happy at the moment um there
might not be more than a draw here for
white which is certainly not what he he
came out for today but as we said these
things just happen and yeah robert what
else
well that means that problem number one
the
opening battle the fight for who has the
better preparation because sam is
suddenly thinking in a position where
his king is the one in danger and
something else to note about these games
vidiq kuzrathi has two minor pieces for
rook in that game against duda so you're
right we haven't seen the duval game
against yes panko i also see magnus's
queen on c1 it's that's a trend in these
cattlemen positions all of a sudden
dubaov did that yesterday against
shanklin but the gujarati game against
judah that
position does not have
a balance so it's very unclear
yeah do you let's go and update david to
that game maybe
absolutely so i just i'm pulling it up
here duda has five or four and a half
more minutes than he started with so
he's gaining time with the increment he
has studied this position vii in perhaps
completely new territory and the last
time we looked knight e5 was played the
rook went up to e7 i think we can
understand why defending the seventh
rank in particular the f7 pawn after
queen h4
b5 was played due to getting a head
start on his queen side expansion rook
d3 fiona i mean when i look at this
position i like the look of it for white
i do too robert um i've been dreaming
ever since we came to this position the
first time i've been dreaming about
getting some attacking chances
against the black king and while the
rook lift is aimed at doing just that we
see that after dudes next move a5 the r
rook swings over to g3 looking down at
the black king as robert was just
highlighting and now uh things started
getting tactical here
honestly at first glance it almost looks
losing for black because if you try to
avoid the pin because queen takes f6 is
a threat with the pawn on g7 pin to go
king to h8 there's going to be a nice
little move here and it's rook takes g7
because you remove the guard of the
knight you give a rook for a pawn you
throw in queen g5 check the king has to
move say to f8 and after queen takes f6
there's checkmate and one threatens so
you want to deal with that checkmate
threat you move your rook back to e84 if
you move your king to g8 it wasn't just
about one rook left here comes the
second one and that's going to be a
checkmate unless you sacrifice your
queen for the rook in which case white
has a completely winning material
advantage with the attack so you cannot
afford to go king to
h8 so that leads me to be like wait if
you can't go king h8 you're in some big
trouble king f8 meets the same fate
after rook takes g7 and knight takes e4
robert having had looked at this at home
with the computer
because from our human human perspective
the position did look very very scary
but duda he didn't break a sweat
no and knight takes e4 giving up two
minor pieces for rook and pawn and at
first the evaluation bar is saying white
is favored but with that deep
preparation studying it for hours and
hours letting the computer sit and think
for such a long period of time with
their super computers and their neural
nets and all the good stuff they work
with you see a4 played the bishop drops
back to d1 and then after f6 the knight
has to retreat now and
it's clear what judah is going for he's
the one with the initiative he's
controlling the open file
white's king isn't in danger but the
bishop being on d1 is a little bit
awkward and the d4 pawn is isolated can
be targeted the rook on e7 defends the
e6 pawn and the g7 pawn so black doesn't
really have anything to worry about in
terms of weak pawns or king safety but
we tend to like the minor pieces against
the rooks when there's
a clear target to work with and right
now it doesn't feel like white has
things to target and on the other side
black can go after this d4 pawn for
example
yeah it's it's a weird position where i
feel like
i
would evaluate the position differently
if i saw the clock times and if i didn't
i think if i didn't see the clock times
i would think oh i quite like this uh
for white and we see vidit has just
played uh knight d3 at least stopping
the queen from coming in to c1 uh for
now
but yeah with the clock times
it feels like uh duda and we see make
another instant move queen d6 it can be
a little bit uncomfortable and i think
village will
will have some work here to do because
always an uncomfortable spot to be
playing not just against a very strong
opponent but knowing you're playing not
just against him but against the engine
which has backed up all the moves he's
playing
that's scary and you could tell on
vivid's face he is trying to calculate
he's trying to remain objective but it's
hard not to think in those terms of what
does my opponent have in store for me
and then you're starting to get worried
but you need to remove that fear you
should be skeptical but you shouldn't be
worried and of course vidit is a
constant professional he is going to
dive deep into this position he is down
quite a bit of time but they only have
15 moves to make until the time control
so he has plenty of time left he has two
minor pieces so before we hop to another
game let's try to figure out where those
minor pieces should go the bishop in
on d1
i'm not seeing where that bishop belongs
exactly the knight on d3 is kind of
needed where it is to stop a rook c1
though that knight if you stabilize the
d4 pawn could make its way to a square
like c5 but i don't believe in that move
as the d4 pawn is absolutely not stable
the knight comes up here there's going
to be pressure here you can wait is rook
take c5 you're going to move did i just
blunder two pieces
for
a rook in return so you have to watch
out for this although it still says
white is doing just fine so
surprisingly it takes
oh hold up so it didn't like my dtx and
want to throw in this check first
and after king f7 only then take on
here and say that white's pawn is pretty
good queen h8 becomes a big threat wow i
mean you know that duda has still
analyzed this position for several more
turns because um this line is scary for
the black king so i'm sure duda will
show us what the
right way forward is
yeah and well uh first of all vidit i
think he will be spending quite a bit of
time here
so we have time to move on but
very impressive preparation by
uh do that indeed maybe we can
quickly unless there is something crazy
happening maybe we can quickly see the
the game between the two russian players
duba fancy panko and then i will go for
a quick break
okay
well there's a queen on f4 not the first
queen we've seen there today and we can
go from the beginning because we haven't
tuned in but it was
guess be surprise a catalan
and it's really i mean uh
interesting to see how much into fashion
the catalan has become again qq world
championship match uh carlson nepam
nyashi and the influence um
i think it was really interesting that
catalan game
in the world championship match which
was the first moment where everyone
started thinking oh duvaf is probably
still on the team
and janna palmer she said that right he
was like as soon as i saw some of these
openings i was like um daniel that seems
like his influence and it is and here
daniel plays queen a4 which is a common
theory you were winning this pawn back
on c4 directly but you've moved your
queen once you're gonna move it twice
and you're gonna have to move it a third
time after b5 so you've opened up your
diagonal the rook on eight is loose but
that's why black makes this move order
b5 hits the queen with tempo the queen
drops back and then bishop b7 so fiona i
played this position from the black side
many times do you have any experience in
these kind of catalan lines i have
actually played the catalan from the
black side as well unfortunately and it
was one of the reasons
i moved away from 1d5 because i got so
depressed
i got so depressed defending this from
the black side
i never had too much fun here i know it
is uh supposed to be very solid but uh
it's quite rare for for black to have
too much fun uh in these lines
that's right because normally the way it
works as can you get this move c5 in and
after you do that you've probably
equalized but if you you every move does
c5 work does c5 work nope okay next turn
does it work nope there's a drawback and
then you see in this game bishop d2
played bishop e4 the queen drops back to
c1 so if the queen wants to be on c1
here if you move off the c file with
like queen to b3 then we see that move
that we're talking about c5 is played
and after pawn takes e5 you could take
back with the bishop but even better is
the move knight to d7 you win this pawn
back it can't move anywhere because it
will be captured and there already are
multiple pieces attacking it so you get
to develop and then bring your knight to
c5 which is really nice for black so
queen goes back to c1 for that reason
bishop b7 back and i i've seen so many
draws with queen c2
bishop e4 and back and forth players if
they're not interested in playing they
do this uh repetition but here we see
duval he doesn't want that he wants
bishop f4 knight d5 and knight c3 is a
fiona giving up the bishop pair
duboff says that's all right with me
because i'm fully developed and
the c5 push is not going to be easy to
make work yeah
and well we can see from the live
position in the bottom right corner that
the c5 push still hasn't happened
getting the bishop piece and the bishop
the bishop here must be worth something
uh but i guess you're liking white's
position here is still or what do you
make of it
yeah in general i still think there's a
slight pull for white and the move
knight e5 was played dubois knows these
positions very well if we take a quick
peek at the clock he has more time than
he started with and the bishops were
swapped on g2 this is our live position
and there's a big problem for black c5
is hard to make work and we're not
joking when we say that this is what the
position is all about and the reason why
if you give white
just even two free turns let's say to
move king h8 just to show you what
happens rook c1 qg8 and then this knight
moves uh away say to knight e4 you have
this huge problem oh i blundered a piece
or something with f6 i guess but the
point is that there's a huge problem
down the c file so i maybe this exact
move order doesn't make the point i'm
trying to make but if we pretend that f6
doesn't exist we see that the c pawn is
just a target white controls the c6
square and that's the issue and now
speaking of f6 in the current position
f6 looks like it might go and win a
piece but white has the move knight c6
and that's why the rook can't be on c1
that's the big difference is because
after bishop takes f4 knight takes d8
there's no rook to capture on c1 so
that's the reason the eval bar went
crazy when i was giving white free turns
and it was still good for black because
in this particular situation once the
queens are traded not for each other uh
directly but through minor piece
captures that if black takes the knight
you take the bishop and c5 guess what
still hard to make work and to equalize
with it yeah and well the chat was just
pointing out the esc panko was staring
into our souls looking at the camera
there but it seems to be the the the
theme of the day so far a lot of players
up so much on the clock having played
everything instantly and uh well yes
panko here still has his work cut out
for him here
we are gonna take a very quick break we
will have our producer big checking in
with the challengers seeing what has
been happening there and we will be back
in just a few minutes so don't go
anywhere
[Music]
yes welcome everyone we're back with
check in with the challengers my name is
walter bick i'm the producer for tattoos
ngs.com so if anything goes wrong
you know how to blame do i either be
robert or fiona either way we're here
checking in with the challengers every
day we're gonna look into the challenger
section see you have some interesting
games next week because they play next
to the masters and the winner will be
playing next year in 2023 master section
of still chess tournament so it's very
important next to the master section and
we have a very nice game here of
international measure pulling the
shivalova against mark modizi and we
have a
pretty interesting position here already
we can see that white is going to snag
off that pawn on h4 so let's just do
this happen in the game
it's blacks to move so they're not going
to snag that off here it is next rook
takes h4
king plate to g7 and here we have our
first
little
meniscus little uh error and it's very
interesting to see why the bar is
dropping down now
the move that should have been played
was rook to c4 let's see for the idea is
you're going to go to c6 you're going to
hit that pawn on b6 because you always
look at these backwards pawns those are
the ones you're trying to grab now black
what black would do they would change
queens and after a queen change here
rook to d6 we could play king f4 and if
we look at this position real quick we
see that this spawn is very weak for
black this spawn is weak for very black
black is this pawn which is also very
weak we have three pawn islands next to
the two part islands of white which are
all neatly defended and that's the big
change of what happened in the game
because what happened in the game and if
you think about that position that we
just had with all these pawn islands
whatever after rook f4 black played a
very smart e5
already pushing down the board and now
rook c4 is a little bit too late because
we keep pushing the pawn down we're
going to e4 and after bishop takes c4
rook to d2 hitting the queen here
looking at checkmate while the bishop is
still defending it however more
important we're also looking at c2
looking at g2 and this knight is looking
at e4 the only defender at the moment
after queen to e1 we had a nice queen
check we had an exchange of queens we
took this bishop and we took the pawn
now the big difference here in the
position that we just had
is not only are the the knights and the
bishop traded off
in addition there are only two palm
islands
uh for black now where are two for white
as well the big difference here in that
is that this is a lot easier to draw
this is already i think a theoretical
draw
with perfect play now perfect play did
not happen i can tell you that there was
a
beautiful move
after black played b5 here now once you
look at this position
i'm going to give you five seconds
and just barber evil white played a
brilliant move beautiful the idea of
black hair
is simply that if you take care on b5
i'm going to put my rook here and
there's no way to defend this pawn or
attack my black pawn and if you start
running i'll just sweeply gen behind it
you're not gonna be in time i will catch
you and now this is uh pretty much a
very easy draw for black the game
however this is not what happened why
play a fantastic move
look at four check i'm sorry it was a
little bit messed up but you already
have to move uh rook for a little
intermezzo just to tickle a little bit
you know get away from the side of the
board here it comes here's the big
finale b4
now the idea this is what happened it's
not what happened in the game but the
idea is that if you take here on a4
b takes a5 and there's no way to really
catch this pawn because i will grab your
pawn here and if you say like well you
know what i'm just gonna start running
for myself then you play rook a4 still
going for the palm
now the same thing applies right here
uh what happened in the game was a
little pawn push
and then you take here the same thing
applies if you start running
i will uh put it behind but black had
one final trick up its sleeve which i
love
very much
after this move after b2 you cannot play
b6
do not be taken for a full after b6
black has the very sneaky idea of
playing rook d4 check distracting you
from this uh position here making sure
that you can queen and if you take i
will queen
and black should is not easy it's not
over you can say that well after let's
say b7
here and here we might even get a some
sort of fortress like this is not an
easily one i would say that this should
be a draw with correct play of y but
it's very difficult to play against
maybe we can make a fortress
but
paulina did not fall for that and after
b2
we quickly played king of three
make sure that we didn't have any
problems this pawn is going to run and
this is where moses
resigned the game and uh please shuffle
over first win in the challenge section
going two and a half out of five at the
top of the top of the leader top of the
pack it's arya and erigasi who had a
brilliant win today as well nice slow
outpace i could have picked that game as
well but i really wanted to show this
game these little nice neat little rook
and game tactics uh that keeps you warm
at night let's uh let's say that
um
thank you hope you guys are enjoying
these little things these little little
tactics that we get going on left and
right uh we're always checking with
challengers but for now we're gonna go
with the big boys in the master section
and let's bring it back to fiona
and robert
hello and welcome back uh it is round
six here at the tata steel chess
tournament we are your hosts for the day
my name is fiona i'm joined by
grandmaster house famously you can't
spell chess without us robert how is
this round uh
shaping up for you so far
well first of all you can spell chess
without my name if you speak another
language so i just there is a workaround
just so everybody knows that they don't
need me at all times but either way i'm
thrilled that everyone can join us for
the show seven games still ongoing here
as we look from board to board
sam shanklin against pragnanda following
the lines that we were predicting
earlier that's in the bottom right hand
side of the screen here the game up top
there the top right it looks like duboff
has planted his knight on c6 and yes
panko has pushed his f pawn that's
interesting mama jarv has decided to
venture forward with his c5 push that's
in the top rope the second from the
right so fiona
we really have so many options even
magnus carlsen he sacrificed the pawn
and now is trying to win it back so i
don't know where our attention should go
but we can't go wrong that's the good
news that's good news indeed i suggest
we maybe start with world champion
magnus carlson he has once again
sacrificed upon
we talked about his catalan opening we
talked about the dub of influence and do
you think that's what's happening here
again
i think it is and the last move played
was b3
because after queen c1 black tried to
protect the pawn and then magnus said i
will go and win it you can't afford to
get gritty because you lose your knight
on c6 so that pawn on c4 is pinned if
you move it you lose that knight and
i mean at first glance i would say that
it's typically the case that when you
gain your pawn back in this manner that
white should be doing pretty well but
this bishop on e3 is particularly
awkward and the rook on b8 is perfectly
situated for when the b-file will open
yeah i think at the moment uh magnus has
yet got some work to do to to convince
us of the soundness of putting the
bishop on e3 in front of its own uh pawn
and i'm also one thing i'm curious about
is magnus's um time consumption because
he is down to an hour meaning he has
spent 40 minutes already to get here
and uh i think
that probably indicates that this might
be at least in some part and over the
world inspiration rather than all at all
being in the books
i'm trying to think how much i believe
him not believe you but believe him
because sometimes players will go and
think they're just trying to recall
preparation or they're making it seem as
if they don't know exactly what they
want to be doing because and it was at
this point here with queen to c1 that
magnus started thinking so it's possible
that bishop d6 caught him off guard very
possible
but it's a normal looking move by report
it shouldn't be
all that shocking to see it
so queen c1 b5 b3 i think the game will
continue with castling and after pawn
takes c4 put you you have to take back
with the pawn otherwise white has too
much control with these pawns here and i
think that white doesn't have to capture
on c4 right away we saw that in a
sideline in the game between
dubaissapanko that the move knight to d2
makes more sense to me i would like to
take this pawn with my knight rather
than bring my queen out into the open
and white does have the healthier pawn
structure fiona because black has two
isolated pawns it's just one for white
yeah something like that uh would
look good but
yeah i'm not i'm very curious to see
what happens here for so far i'm not
convinced richard he looks very um
very focused here he's also not too sure
probably just how much he should believe
magnus and well i think we'll come back
here he's taking his time as he should
to figure out how he wants to meet uh b3
and both players being intentionally
deliberate they don't want to make any
big mistakes here because the structure
is one where yeah the c file is going to
be open the c7 pawn the backwards pawn
could be a nuisance to deal with so
you're right report will probably think
quite a bit so we can look at some other
games
i know that the chat
wanted to to catch up
with the sam shanklin i think a lot of
people are are very interested
with what's going on there so they have
they repeated once maybe we can very
quickly
update that
yeah queen to e3 queen a5 check queen c3
and queen to b6 so it's not a full-on
repetition of moves because the queen
didn't go back to a7 here but i do think
the queen is better placed on b6 and i
don't see a better move for white than
to play queen e3 because if you take on
b5 you lose the game
right away queen takes f2 check if your
king goes back to the first rank you
lose the rook because you lose the
connection between your ropes and if you
go up to d3
even e4 check should be sufficient
because after e4 your king has to go up
here to c4 and then i can give you a
check along the c file and just take
your queen so
the king will never find shelter and
you're losing material so that would be
bad news for shanklin so he has to i
think fiona play the move queen e3
yeah i think that sam is
it's a different kind of going through
the motions sometimes we see it happen
uh before resignation but i think here
um unfortunately for some maybe he will
have to resign himself
to to this not being more than a draw i
think some um he is still looking i
think he wants to avoid the repetition
but
maybe there just isn't anything and i
think most likely and we'll see a
handshake here in the near future
all right the problem for shanklin is
that f2 is hanging which means king is
in danger a4 is also under attack and
he's only one pawn it's not like he's up
two pawns and can afford to give one
back and try to play for an advantage i
think if he loses his material edge he's
just going to be in trouble because his
king will never find safety the bishop
on g6 is scary though so if white could
play queen f3 queen h5 we've been
talking about this checkmate but the
queen will then get to the d4 square and
then this king on d2 it's just much
easier to attack it so fiona i guess my
biggest question is i let sam shankle's
reputation precede him his opening
knowledge is always great he seems like
he knows what he's doing in pretty much
any line he's been very vocal about how
hard he works especially on the opening
stages and of course he's great at other
elements of the game as well
but maybe his preparation wasn't super
thorough here because it seems that with
pragananda's prep he was able to get a
position where it should just be a draw
by repetition
and that means that program didn't have
to sweat it out over the board finding
some
tactics to defend or you know a grinded
out position where you're slightly worse
than an end game no he just played what
he worked on and at the board he's just
going to it looks like make is wrong
yeah it's hard to say i mean it could
also be i think sometimes
you have these huge files and there is
this one or two lines where if black
finds everything
then it will just peter out into
intro draw and this is could be what
what happened here uh sam might have
gotten his hopes up because pragnanda
was spending some time so we will maybe
find out after the game if prague gets
asked about it did he actually know all
this was it a matter of just remembering
was it a matter of
sometimes it's a mix you have seen it
before but you're trying to remember
over the world
so that could be the answer but
at the end of the day
prague has found
all uh all the best moves and
sam's preparation here unfortunately for
him doesn't seem to be yielding him any
any advantage
all right and we can um you know talk
about this a lot and sometimes you do go
down variations where
only one move for your opponent holds
but the type of player i wouldn't test
their theory and at least to this extent
and i'm kind of walking back what i was
saying earlier is pragnanda i thought
that he was venturing into sam
shanklin's uh cooking right his home
prep all that good stuff but it seems
like pragnanda knows it just as well if
not better and so pragnanda the lowest
rated player in the field the least
experienced just because he's the
youngest
he is the type of player who is going to
put up great resilience no matter what
but i feel like if you're one of the
higher rated players you don't
necessarily want to just say let's see
who can
work better at home you want to try to
outplay them over the board but all
credit to pragnanda so far having a
great event beat niels grandilius has
been in every single game playing some
really high level chess yeah and well we
haven't talked about it but pregnant he
got a double black
yesterday he was on the losing end of a
tough game i mean he he got a great
position we fought out of the opening
then slightly lost his ways
and lost the tough game in the end
against richard report and all kudos to
him for today uh
getting another black
being faced with some
uh some big preparation by sam he didn't
lose his cool and
yeah it looks like
it looks like to me this is going to be
ending
quite shortly as we see sam there some
is visibly and not happy looking at the
score sheet
pulling a little bit of a face he was
reaching out maybe we can wait uh if he
makes a move
soon because it could just uh just be
over here in this moment at 7. no he's
changed his mind he's going to take
another thing i think he's desperately
looking for something to keep the game
going but now queen e3 has just appeared
on
the board and well now the question is
pregnant uh queen a5 would be repeating
it wouldn't be a draw just yet
but
also for prague i'm not sure i don't
think there isn't anything else for him
either anything better
right because trading queens would win
this pawn back on a4 here but as you see
the
bar skyrocket and the game is uh
following that just to show this quickly
if we get a position like this where we
trade everything the bishop on g6 wins
white the game you say rook a1 your rook
gets active and the bishop helps out in
a way that leaves black with little
choice for the past pawn the rook is
going to go after this d6 pawn it's just
a terrible situation for a black
actually wait is black down two pawns
can i not even count right
have i been counting wrong this whole
time black is down two pawns
and i never corrected you at any point
because
i just trusted you robert wait a second
black has been down two pawns this whole
time and nobody said anything
[Laughter]
oh well
we all trust you too much robert that's
our problem
yeah b5 was pawn one and then h5 was uh
was pawn two okay now i get it
i get it now math
you need to work on it
and by the way we are now uh in the
position
where the moves have been repeated a
couple of times f2 is under attack again
the black queen is back on b6 and if sam
plays queen e3 now uh prague will be
able to claim a draw after
um
queen a5 or even sam can play my draw
here by playing queen
between e3 so i think we'll see a
handshake here
sam looks very frustrated though yeah he
looks really disappointed because he had
the white pieces and if you're going to
strike against anybody in this field you
know that's the player you'd want to go
into you want to beat them in chess
while they're young before they have a
chance to
gain their rating to be 27.50 right when
you were going to beat alireza ferrugia
it had to be when he was like 14 and
still finding his footing now that ali
reza is in his later teenage years and
is 2800 plus okay that time has passed
yes indeed and uh but it wasn't to be
today for
um we've looked at this position plenty
and i think here we're literally just
waiting for some to to make the move
queen e3 and for the game
to be over
i don't know if we're gonna keep the
camera on the players and move on to
another bird so we don't miss the
handshake
and well let's bring back the the bird's
eye view
and robert
a lot happening there's so many pieces i
find it so much harder to take the
positions in when there's so many pieces
on the board
because my my stair gets
goes everywhere but what is catching ui
most well we were looking at it briefly
earlier in the game as we visited
gujarati and young chis second from the
left on the top row knight c5 was in
fact played which means that duda can
take that knight and take the bishop on
d1 but we're talking about how tricky
that position was and duda has spent a
lot of time here fiona he
his knowledge of this opening and he's
really past the opening by far at this
point 26 moves into the game
it's done it's over so i think for vidid
you could have a sense of relief that
you're no longer facing pure preparation
all this engine analysis now it seems
that duda is on his own
yeah and well it will be interesting to
see if he takes on c5 or goes for
something else i also see that uh on the
bottom right second from the right
jordan van forest his bishop from b8 has
made it back to a7 where it started out
and jordan has just played the knight to
the rim of course the knight doesn't
want to stay there it will be looking to
jump into f4 maybe we can briefly check
in there
sure thing knight on h5 knight on g6 i
think we know where those knights are
heading they share
one square
in common it's the f4 square and that
usually gives black some serious chances
for an attack because the bishop on c8
it may not look developed but it still
threatens the sacrifice on the h3 square
this queen can come to f6
i typically enjoy playing these
positions from the black side but you
have to acknowledge that white has this
wonderful center and control with these
pawns from c4 to e4 i like you fiona
sometimes i just get in the mood for
some kind of vicious attack and with the
queen coming in the knight joining the
party and a potential sack on h3 i think
white needs to be very careful yeah i
mean this is the typical position where
i tend to get a little sometimes too
optimistic sometimes my
my optimism gets rewarded sometimes it
isn't but yeah i love what you're
showing there bringing the queen to f6
the knight to f4
and and i think that's exactly what
jordan is going to be be looking to do
on the other hand
if you are white how do you want to
start preparing for this onslaught
against your king one of the moves
you're going to play at some point is
bishop to f1 because it defends your
king side and also opens up the d file a
white wants to play energetically but
with the position the way it currently
sits and in particular the bishop on d3
is not a very good piece
bad bishops defend good pawns and this
bishop has two pawns very good ones that
it defends but it's in the queen's path
on the d-file so move like bishop f1 as
a starting point makes sense because
after this move white can decide do i
want to take on e5 do i want to push
this pawn to d5 you have two different
styles of play here and one thing that
really annoys me is this knight on c3 is
dominated by this pawn on c6 so uh the
knight can't jump forward even though
it's good on its current square and
honestly i'm still seeing this move
queen f6 fiona bishop takes h3 on the
horizon knight coming into f4
i would enjoy to play this from the
black side more than from white
yeah for sure we see the the engine
disagrees
uh with us it prefers right position but
i think from a practical
point of view um
black just has the more the more active
choices there's a lot of threats in the
position
and i think jordan will be will be quite
happy with what he got here
and one big question that i'm trying to
figure out is can white defend the king
side by attacking something else
distracting black's pieces
i'm trying to make a move like d5 work
and the reason why i believe it does
work is because bishop takes h3 if white
were to take back on h3 you see that's
bad because the queen that's not the
queen that's the pawn queen takes knight
and black is one upon and the king is in
a bad way but instead of just taking
back on h3 you take on a7 and after the
rook takes back you don't want to be
down a piece there's this mcqueen e3
hitting that rook that is now hanging
protecting the knight on f3 and this
doesn't finish the story black can
continue sacrificing with move like
bishop g2 and after bishop g2 just move
the rook away and say your king doesn't
have pawns in front of it i have the f4
square for my knight so i can see what
the eval bar says but as someone trying
to get in the mindset of the players
this does look a bit nerve-wracking if
i'm thinking about it from white's
perspective of course cardiac and a very
objective player and he's great at
defense but it would be scared i would
be at least to see a knight coming at 4.
i think
a very interesting match up here of
styles as well because karjakin he as
you said is not afraid to defend
positions i was going to say worse
positions this one i don't think is
worse so he is on the defending
end but jordan also not afraid to give
up some material and
try and
get some attacking chances so bishop f1
has been played i think uh there is very
good chances we'll see either queen f6
or knight f4 first and i think this game
is about to
to spring into life very soon and not a
single piece has been traded yet that
does not mean that there isn't quite a
lot of action and there is so
this you know a7 bishop it came back to
life from b8 and it likely will be
traded off in the future and i think
that white is going to have to do
something in the center try to open up
the position but not
i don't think take on e5 because if you
trade on e5 i think even in this manner
it's awkward for a moment for your rook
to be on
a7 but controlling the f4 square is
really important i think that black
doesn't have any targets
that that white won't be able to target
black's pieces with this pawn on e5 here
whereas when you play d5 at some point
you may take on c6 and go for this d6
pawn that d6 pawn isn't super healthy
yeah and well we'll see what jordan
decides on we'll see how does sergey
react in the center very interesting
stuff we will come back here let's bring
back the bird's eye view one more time
we see that sam
there the head has just gone down
uh into into the arms and i think
he is about
to resign himself to going queen e3 and
uh and the draw will be agreed
elsewhere what do we have uh going on
duraff against the ese panko we see that
yes panko never got around to getting in
uh c5 and now the white knight has found
its way into
d6 and could yes bank will be in some
trouble here robert
this is certainly worse for yesapanko
and he is not going to be happy to have
this position it's i could already
envision the post game interviews uh
dubois saying i got everything i won i
was better with white you know the
control of the c file and the last few
moves f6 was played and after knight c6
yes panko didn't want the end game he
could have taken the queen given up his
own and after the trade on the d8 square
let's say with this rook take care you
could play for c5 that's what we keep
talking about but even these end games
are worse for black and the reason why
is with b4 the knight is kicked back to
an uncomfortable square like b7 you
don't want to go in front of your rook
in the open file and allow white to
infiltrate so these types of positions
can be just worse for black despite the
even material and white having the
double pawns the king is slightly more
active the knight will hop into e4 so
this would be slightly better for white
even if black could hold a position like
this but the way yes of panko is playing
he kept the queens on the board fiona
but i think his position is just so
unpleasant now where the c pawn is the
permanent target
and did we is that the position on the
board i thought
it is
but then i was hallucinating in the the
birds i viewed somehow i thought there
was a night on seas did i look at
another game no no the night was there
and they just quickly traded yeah okay
i thought i was losing my mind there for
a second and yeah well the position we
have on the board now
i mean if i was just a panko i would
prefer uh would have preferred that
slightly inferior position i think that
you were just showing in the in the end
game
because here okay well the bishop
is looking down this diagonal now rook
c1 looks like the logical move putting
that
on the c file
um and
again just robert black is just never in
time to get in c5 c5 right now none of
the black
pieces controlling that square
um i don't think black wants to give up
the bishop for the knight because then
white would have everything he dreams of
control of the c file of the d file
the pawn on f5 is not ideally placed
there so
that's not what black wants but
getting tough
to give good advice here to to black
after rook c1
can i
as black can i try at some point maybe
start by playing c6 to defend my pawn on
b5 and then try and break with a5
it's definitely a worthwhile attempt and
you also take away the d5 square from
all of white's pieces i mean the knight
was threatening to hop their queen d5
check could have been annoying even rook
d5 to put pressure on the bishop so c6
is a good first move but we see that
it's going to be a permanent problem
with this pawn on c6 and i want to move
my knight to b1 knight retreating moves
are always fun and now c6 is under
attack this knight come to d2 to b3 and
this is not an enjoyable situation for
yes banco no it's not gonna be a fun day
at the office for him and if we look at
the clock times uh dupe of over 40
minutes
up on the clock so i suggest we leave
this game for now and we go back one
more time to the bird's eye view but
looking good so far for
duboff and maybe robert we can check in
with some of our tournament leaders what
do you think for sure i mean we see that
vivid is still thinking over there i
would say the mama jarv game has changed
the most in
recent moves so maybe we should go there
and see how this one is developed
because
white has sort of pawn phalanx on the
queen side and black has pushed that
pawn to f5 to open up the bishop on g7
you were mentioning this many moves ago
that that bishop once it comes to life
that could be a problem for white to
deal with but the last couple moves were
after bishop g7 c5
and b4 i always enjoy seeing the move b4
because the knight can capture it but
mom and jarv assess that once you take
b4 if you take b4 you're opening up the
b file and i give up my pawn for yours
in return and this is a very good trade
for white and sorry robert to interrupt
you but funnily enough the the cameras
above us hadn't switched yet in the
beginning and we were looking at the
divided uh duda game on the camera and
just as you're explaining what's going
on in this position dude actually
decided to take on c5 as so we're gonna
go down that uh that queen ending in in
this game
okay so uh just to quickly finish off
the thoughts of this one you're not
going to take on b4 he doesn't want any
part of that and the position is one
where the bishop on e6 doesn't look
great but it does hold black's position
together for now white may advance on
the queen side with an extra pawn but
let's go to that video game against duda
i mean that just we have to with the
change in the position and the material
yeah so uh duda really sunk into a very
very long thing here in this position
after that it's knight c5
trying to decide uh i can take the two
pieces back and i will be up upon uh but
white's passed pawn on the c file will
be only three squares away from queening
so how do i evaluate this position
position
position and do that decided well this
is actually something i want to go for
has played queen d2 now hitting the pawn
uh on f2
and
as so often robert the engine just says
zero zeros
the two pawns are hit
as white i would be looking for
something negative and the queen that
you the move that you suggested earlier
comes to mind queen h8 uh asking some
questions as to what black is going to
do about the pawn on g7
and black is currently upon ahead and
this is what duda was thinking about so
his preparation from what he knew to
play instantly had ended
he was double triple checking that this
line would work out we see the zeros on
the eval bar and the reason why is after
queen h8
blackheads will pawn to f5 because
you're
in a big attack rook take g7 would be
checkmate if you push g6 you lose the h7
pawn and your whole protection falls
apart so f5 is the move and look at how
strong this queen is on day four it
attacks two of white's pawns and
protects black's pawn on g7 and after
queen takes h7 here you cannot take
either pawn from black's perspective
because the g7 pawn is still hanging so
what duda has in store for us after that
move queen takes h7 is interesting i
don't think we should just get purely
defensive with a move like queen f6
because we cannot forget about white's
past pawn and the king still feels a
little bit iffy once the queen comes to
h5 with check i think that black may try
to make it like rook c7 and go after the
pawn on
c5 though the queen coming to g6 is also
worrisome so i'm throwing out moves here
with rook c7 but now after queen g6
check g7 e6 both need defending it's
really a position that needs to be
calculated thoroughly you can't just
make moves here and hope that they work
out
yeah and do that well the good news for
him is he's got plenty of time on the
clock as he uh
had blitzed out everything up to move
pretty much 20
25 so we'll see what he has in store for
us we're gonna go on a quick break i saw
that some people in the chat were asking
uh where can they watch the the game
challenge talk which has just started 15
minutes ago so some of our mods are
watching we'll make sure that the link
is posted in the chat and robert will be
back with the action here from rn6 in
just a few minutes
[Music]
do
i remember coming here uh first time was
2015 i was playing the b section i had a
fantastic result i made plus five but
wei yi was an absolute terminator
i played him with white in round one and
it was a draw and it was just i never
had a chance again if i had known that
he was going to go nuts maybe i would
have pushed a little harder
i remember at first it was chorus chess
before it was taught at steele and i
always remembered this was like the the
most important tournament of the year
the biggest best one
tata steel chest room and you know they
call it the wimbledon of trust and i
think they've earned that name uh it's
just the best term in the world
obviously you know with magnus in the
field and i'm in the bottom half the
odds are against me but you know if the
best player always won chess will be a
very boring game i'm just going to play
my best and if the points come that way
they will
so i use technology for opening
preparation for sure but that's more or
less the only thing i use it for i think
i'm more scared in terms of the future
of trust if computers just processing
faster and then if they become a little
bit stronger i worry that one day chess
can be weakly solved
luckily i still think that day is very
very far away and i think it will be
after i'm retired many many years in the
future
it was a very memorable tournament for
me both with positive and negative
attributes last time but i'm really
looking forward to playing again this
year
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round six here
at the tata steel
chess tournament and robert we
still have sam on the camera after
watching his portrait he really does not
want to make that draw but queen e3 here
will be a three-fold repetition and
unfortunately there is just no choice
if he's upset about making the draw
he'll be far more upset if he doesn't
make the draw there he goes he's moved
his queen to e3 that is um a look of
i wish i had done something differently
today his extensive preparation it went
quite deep in the line but pragnando's
went further he is going to earn himself
a half point and without too much
difficulty from the black side so i have
the wrong game up there i'll bring the
repeating of moves and then we just saw
the handshake with pragnanda looking at
his sheets he was making a double
checking that he could claim uh the move
so there's a whole presidio if you're
new to chess if you want to claim a
three-fold repetition you have to first
write down the move that you want to
make on your score sheet then you call
over the arbiter and you say that's the
move i'm going to make it will be a
three-fold repetition
and that's how you claim the draw so
when sam
stopped fragmented looking at his
scoresheet he just himself for federal
we saw a handshake and yeah very
impressive
by pragnanda today who withstood all the
assaults of sam's really very deep
preparation
for sure and and we saw them talking
briefly about the position
and
he was i think sam asked him what would
you have done if i'm queen takes b5
and
uh we see the players with the arbiters
just talking uh quickly gonna get head
out of there but at the moment i'm
pretty sure sam asked
what would you have done if i took your
bishop
and what do you think prague said
i think he she told him rook to b8 so we
can pull up that position you know one
last time yeah um and show everybody
but it looks like uh the players have
left
the hall over there
or they're in the process of leaving so
all right we see the draw has been made
what are you confused about robert
all right i mean i wasn't hearing you
were you talking because i i didn't no
no no i'm sorry
no sorry i was waiting for you to make
the move
oh no i don't have a board in front of
me to make the move
because i can see the the board
oh you don't
okay let's um
hey maybe we can just leave this one
because i can see the board fine so i'm
not sure
what's going on maybe we just bring back
the the bird's eye view and we can check
back in here uh later
well i think it's on my end so i'm gonna
try to fix things here and get back in
this call real quick because i yeah i'm
not seeing anything that you are
sure no so i'm gonna uh have a look at
the bird's eye view and what do we see
well the first thing that catches my
eyes of course the vidiq gujarati
against
of duda
nothing has happened there uh duda is uh
sorry vidit is still thinking after
judah's last move queen to d4 robin and
i had a look at the queen going to h8
but certainly there are other options
the position seems to be in the balance
now but still very dynamic
and then magnus carlsen well things
have a change there we see
report has just captured on c4 we'll see
if magnus captures back immediately or
robert talked about
the possibility of going knight to d2
and robert i'm just gonna talk for as
long as until
okay um so
i'm
just gonna decide which game do i go to
i think i'm gonna
i'm gonna go to the do both
you know what i'll go to you then you're
the inventory sorry i know we came from
there not too long ago
but uh
we left things off here after sergey
karjakin went bishop to f1 we were
talking about a queen coming to f6 a
knight jumping to f4 and jordan decided
to start with queen f6
we talked about there now being some
threats of bishop takes h3 with the
knight hanging on f3 and actually sergey
went down one of the lines that robert
had shown us
with d5
and now the problem being that if you
capture on
h3 and word welcome back
i am back indeed sorry about that some
technological issues but i am indeed
here i see you're highlighting the h3
pawn uh the attack that is potentially
brewing for jordan von forest yeah and
well i think that we had looked at
this
exact uh line before so i was just going
to highlight one more time that bishop
h3 doesn't work immediately so instead
jordan decided to take on e3
and decided to keep the center closed by
going as c5
yeah this move makes perfect sense
because the target is the d6 pawn but
it's a lot harder to go after it when
the d file is closed so fiona with the
action
heating up on the king side and now the
center being closed that should be nice
for black but white was able to get the
move g3 and just in time taking away the
f4 square
yeah and suddenly well we
played all these preparatory moves
knight to h5 queen to f6 all with the
idea of getting something
on
the king side either some bishop h3
tactics or a knight to f4
this seems to all have been paired now
so as black i guess we need to rethink
our plans and and maybe shuffle the
pieces around again the night on age
five now not doing much uh they're
not doing much there any longer
so uh how do we reshuffle here is black
what's our new plan
well jordan played a4 and he feels that
his pawn is safe enough there because he
could put his bishop on d7 but i'm with
you that knight on h5 isn't super happy
the queen can retreat to e7 or d and
then the knight can come back in the
game but white
is the one calling the shots the side
that controls the pawn breaks is usually
the side with the advantage and white
can try to break open on the queen side
at some point by bringing the rook to b1
trying to play move like b3 or b4 so i
do like sergey's position i think he's
done a great job
yeah i agreed and well we'll have to see
what jordan comes up with here
but i'm glad you're back
and this game well we'll leave it until
a little bit later we're going to go
to the the bird's eye view and there's a
couple of games i feel we haven't
checked in with in a little while
okay well we have all six remaining
games on screen i see vidit's pawn has
gone up to c6 he doesn't care about the
attack he wants to promote that pawn
we'll see if duda will be able to take
care of that that's the second board
from the left in the top row and magnus
and rapport they've been honestly not
moving very quickly so they both are
thinking spending their time and trying
to figure out the proper way forward and
then i see nils i was just gonna say
that robert
he made the move g5 which is only a
temporary pawn sacrifice because and
there it goes mamarov takes the pawn on
g5 d4 can be captured and niels said in
his interview yesterday after his game
i'm thinking about this as a whole new
tournament is looking like a whole
different meals
indeed i mean neil's and i think he
really has got that strength of
character he is a very optimistic person
by nature very cheerful and it's it's
impressive to see how he uh just moved
on from from uh what has been
a bad start from him started on half out
of four drew magnus yesterday and today
he's really going for it with the black
pieces against co-leader shahid mahmud
diarov as you're highlighting there he's
putting that pressure on the pawn on d4
mahmoud diref defended with rook d1 and
here comes
g5 a bald out of the blue the pawn is
only defended by the black queen it's
hit two times but if you take it then
the the pawn on on d4 is going to fall
right and the threat has to go g4 and
one little note here but an important
one that mama drove chose the f rook to
come to d1 if you want rook a to d1
we're talking about after knight takes
b4 there was rook to b1 but then you'd
have to spend another turn moving this
rook back towards the queen side and
guess what you've lost the defender for
your d4 pawn so mama jarv decided to
deal with both threats but bring his f
rook to d1 moving uh
this rook here g5 knight takes g5 and
fiona after knight takes g5
right here queen takes d4 forces the
queens off the board because the knight
on c3 is hanging and the rook behind it
so after queen takes d4 white will have
to deal with that by playing queen takes
d4 knight takes d4 and
i like this bishop on g7 yeah
black of course has damaged his pawn
structure uh by playing g5 and that pawn
was traded for the pawn on d4 so niels
now finds himself with an oddly looking
pawn structure
with the pawn on the double isolated
pawns on the f file the isolated pawn on
d5 and an isolated pawn
on h7 but i think what you're saying the
bishop pair and especially the bishop on
g7 controlling that long diagonal white
doesn't have a dark squared bishop any
longer so he cannot contest the diagonal
more than makes up for the damage pawn
structure
and i thought you're going to mention
the pawn on e6 as well it's a great pawn
there
this actually
is holding all of black's position
together this bishop on e6 protecting d5
protecting f5 protecting f7 protected by
f7 so if the knight were ever to take on
e6 the pawn replaces it and does what
the bishop is doing so black is going to
play a5 at some point trying to open up
this line for the rook if you ever push
the b pawn c5 becomes a target so i
really like the look of this position
for niels grandilius he has been a
completely different player in these
last two rounds yeah i mean really
energetic play here by niels i like his
position we see shakira mahmedyarov
looking
somewhat concerned i don't think that
this is a position he wanted to find
himself
into i think if both if that players
could choose i think both of them would
like to play this uh from the the black
side but for
can he
no the the
trade of queens is first and i think
neil is here the one in control
he is and mama jarv certainly knows it
the pawn structure may not look pretty
for black but it's about the peace
activity the queens have to come off the
board because of the threat on the
knight on c3 and as we were just showing
once this knight takes back the knights
on d4 you get out of this diagonal
because the threat is to go knight takes
e2 check the knight would have to take
back and you lose the rook on a1 so
let's say you play rook b1 or rook c1 uh
i think the move a5 is happening because
if you push b5 i was talking about this
before now i can show it the c5 pawn is
loose you cannot move your knight to
defend the pawn because this knight on
d4 attacks the bishop so i think this
would actually cost white a pawn and the
bishop pair especially this bishop one
g7 fiona it looks like all of neil's
pieces are working together so
harmoniously and i think it's so
important for nils that he managed to
save that draw against magnus yesterday
because it suddenly looked like he was
in huge trouble uh leaving the the first
time control and i think that makes a
big difference for your your
self-confidence and going into the next
game in a good mood whether you lose
another one and you're on half out of
five or whether you take a draw of
magnus carlsen and i'm very happy for
nils he
is back and uh well he is giving shahia
a tough tough test here
and on paper this was one of the more
favorable pairings of the round mama
jarv two straight wins he joined the
leaders bid it and
um report and now he just trades queens
and you can see by his face he's like i
need to figure out a way to equalize
this game and he can do it let's not
make it sound like it's just winning for
nils of course not but the problem for
mama jarvis game continues is that
black's pieces are going to be far more
active and once neos takes back let's
say put the rook on b1 because we keep
talking about a5 as the move and you
play a3 let me just trade
off the pawns you lose a piece because
rook a3 takes the knight
then fish money too
wow i mean i didn't see that one coming
this tells you that even in the position
even after the queen's off um you have
more positional considerations in mind
most of the time but very careful uh
especially well
loose pieces drop off the bishop only
two here
being very loose so always be on the
lookout for uh tactics such as this one
yeah this is just uh not going to be
enjoyable for mama jara but if anybody
can dig deep and hold a position like
this it is chakriar he is known for his
creative style and his tactics but he
obviously is fantastic at all stages of
the game in fact one of the recent
criticisms of mohammed yarb is that
maybe he's gone too much in the
direction of being solid and being
practical so
he can do it he's really been working
hard on his game and somehow he's just
overlooked by the chess community but
for those who have followed top level
chess for a long time they know just
what kind of player mama jarv is and
just because he may be worse right now
you mentioned those bad pawns for black
if niels doesn't keep up with his peace
activity if he isn't finding the
accurate moves forward from here he's
the one who could be in some trouble
just because his pawns are weak
yeah we'll come back to this game and
very curious to see how this one
develops can niels make use of that big
bishop on g7 will shock find enough time
to play we will come back here uh
robert i see at first sight that the
game between duba faniasipanko has
evolved quite a bit
it really has and he
he being yes panko used your
continuation he was able to break free
with the move a5 it hasn't solved all of
his problems but i do appreciate his
position more now that he has
broken open the a file so we just go
back a few turns c6 your suggestion
knight b1 rook f6 making sure you don't
drop a pawn and after knight d2 played
a5 so fiona you saw it all coming you
realize that black can't sit passively
because white was one move away from
playing knight b3 and clamping down on
both the a5 and c5 squares yeah it's
such a relief for estee panko to get a5
in before the knight lands
on b3 uh the pawns were swapped on a5
and finally jesse panko getting some
active play uh
of his own now the first question is
that pawn on
a2 which you have just highlighted
what happens if that's captured that
took me way too long to see
i i knew what you were saying but i also
knew that you saw the reason why you
can't play it so you were trying to ask
a question that was leading but you knew
the answer so a rook takes a2 would be a
very bad choice when a king is on an
exposed diagonal you always have to look
out for checks queen b3 check hits the
rook hits the king if you block with
queen f7 you lose sight of the bishop on
e5 so you'll just go down a piece and if
you put queen e6 hoping that oh if you
trade me my rook comes here i protect
the bishop i'm not going to take your
queen i'm going to take your bishop
because your queen is pinned on e6 which
means you can't take my rook and if you
take on b3 i have my knight here
defending why would we have a piece and
win the game yeah and once again what we
talked earlier about that pawn on f5 and
at a lot of the limes you would want
that pawn to be back on f7 to offer more
shelter to your king
so yeah that king
always in a precarious situation along
that open
open diagonal
so that answered that question we cannot
take the pawn uh on a2
and white rook c5 i like that move a lot
both looking down the the fifth rank so
putting pressure on the bishop on e5
indirectly on the pawn on f5 and also
getting ready to potentially double the
rooks with rook c1
just an unpleasant position for
yesopanko because
when you get in a position like this one
of the things that i like to do is try
to think
what trades will benefit me what future
position can i have that even if i go
down a pawn let's say can i hold one
example of this is and this is very far
down the line but if
the pieces remaining are a rook and
three pawns so essentially these pieces
for black and then a rook and the four
pawns for white then being down that
pawn
often is a theoretical draw despite
being a full pawn down and end game with
the rooks on the board that could be a
draw so it's very far away but that's
something that yes panko has in the back
of his mind i i may lose c6 and b5 for
a2 at some point but can i trade enough
pieces to hold on
yeah so those are some of the questions
he is thinking about his time is
dropping uh down well we already on move
27 so 14 moves to go but also something
to keep an eye on and tube off true to
himself he's been playing
very fast and he is putting on the
pressure here with the white pieces
and you're pointing out that f5 pawn the
diagonal there's so many issues for
black to deal with c6 pawn as well uh
you you can make a sort of passive move
like rook a6 just to defend this pawn on
c6 but just because you have everything
defended in the immediate position
doesn't mean that all your problems are
gone and let's say i play queen e3 look
there's a pin you have to
save your bishop and the only way to do
that is rook to e6 and then i play
knight oh i just blended with knight f3
it's a bishop no there's no bishop d6
here because while it looks like you are
getting my
rook on c5 while attacking my queen i
thought it blundered but then i'm
realizing that even though it's not
check with the knight coming to g5 the
king is in just harm's way permanently
you win a rook that's an incredible move
queen b3 just giving up the full rook on
c5 and saying well i'm going to take
yours back and there's nothing you can
do about it
it's why king safety is so so important
i mean black would just
be losing this game because of the
attack against the king
so uh yeah yeah sepenko he's got his
work cut out for him here let's bring
back the overview i saw that a lot of
people in the chat would like to check
in with anish giri it's true we haven't
been there in a in a long time so let's
go to fabiano and anish
okay well looks like anish is the
happier camper of the two and anish beat
fabiano in the candidates tournament so
i mentioned that they played about 35 or
so classical chess games i believe the
score is even between the two players
but anisha won a very important game in
the candidates that
eliminated fabiano from his chances to
win it and as we look at this position
fiona zero pieces have been traded still
yeah what a what a mess i feel like
robert can we please go back a few moves
and see how we landed here
because there's pieces absolutely all
over the board
and fabiano you know went for e5 uh the
bishop came to c5 some pressure here so
he decided to play e5 kick the knight
back and then went knight to f1 so it's
like the king's indian attack in a way
where white wants to play h4 maybe
knight to h2 or knight e3 and start
attacking the black king because there
aren't that many pieces over towards
that black king and that's why a niche
first place queen d8 it helps the king's
safety but more importantly more
forcefully threatens b5 and we saw him
play knight c7 and after king h1b5 so
the move king h1 fiona
it's not
you know it's a slow move going for an
attack
but
anisha's attack if you want to call it
that is coming first yeah so king h1
stepping out of that diagonal that the
bishop on c5 was looking down at
maybe an idea is in the future to move
the knight from f3 push the f-pawn but
as robert just said black's uh play is
coming a lot faster suddenly b5
is uh on the board
and fabiano has made his next move which
is knight to d4 so knight to d4
attacking the pawn uh on c6
but things are getting messy here
the opening of the queen side is bad
news for white just like i was
mentioning that the black king doesn't
have too many defenders over there
although there's no attack so it doesn't
need to be protected just yet white has
moved all of his pieces away from the
queen side so if for example white had
taken on b5 rather than
playing knight d4 after pawn takes b5 a4
is coming the rook on c8 perfectly
placed the rook on a8 in the right
position so the pawn can march up the
board and that justifies completely
anisha's understanding to play rook f to
c8 so many moves ago he he knew the
direction of the game he knew that he
needed to play for b5 his knight that
was on f6 wrapped around a c7 and he is
doing everything correctly in this game
fiona
yeah anish really seems to have
demonstrated so far the the superior
understanding
or
well he has just
gotten to the punch faster shall we say
and
i'm very curious to see his next move i
wonder do you have to defend
uh on c6 i don't think you want to take
on on d4 and give up this beautiful
bishop uh from c5
um although the engine seems to think
that even this is favoring black
and the reason why is because black
continues pressing forward moves like c5
and the bishop has to go back to the
corner so the bishop on a1 isn't that
great because the pawn e5 is here right
bad bishops defend good pawns it's a
great pawn i like it there but it's uh
seems to be a position where black will
then open uh use the open file excuse me
and then start trying to make progress
but i agree with you i would not take on
d4 anish also agrees with you and he
takes on c4 says have c6 i move my queen
out of the way and once you recapture on
a4 this knight comes to b6 a4 is under
attack c6 is under attack this is really
bad situation for fabiano yeah this is
really looks like travel and i wonder is
fabiano already going to lose some
material by four so can he hold on to to
everything somehow after he takes a4
maybe
i'm not comfortable here but maybe you
have to take c6 take a4 and black will
get that pawn back that was sacrificed
temporarily but black has the outside
pass pawn black has the pressure in the
position
fiona i mean this is a dream situation
for an ishkiri and anish well he um
anish he is currently what's he on he's
on
on two out of five minus one he hasn't
won a game yet but if he can beat
fabiano here with the black pieces that
would be a huge win and we talked about
haniel said you know and this is a new
tournament starting i can say it is such
a long event 13 rounds
and that would be absolutely the result
that anish is looking for to restart his
tournament in a way
yes this would be a great win for niche
and it could kickstart a second half
that could see him even go further up
the standings because he's already
played magnus carlson he's playing
favana right now who's the second
highest rated player in the tournament
so anish has played many of the top
players and that means that
while we know how strong players
all through the event are and he did
play probably not in the first round but
those are the players if everything is
on the line you typically want to play
lower rated players
than the higher rated players but
something fiona i want to say here is
i'm i've been really confused by
fabiano's opening choice he played this
double fianchetto position it's not what
he typically does not just in terms of
you know it's a rare choice at the high
level regardless but from his style he's
such a principal player and i really
wonder why he decided to play
b3 g3 and all this stuff against anish
giri i feel like he's been frustrated
that he hasn't been winning games but as
we see here
he's looking like he's going to lose a
game before he'll win one yeah and
you've got to feel for fabiano because i
i get what you're saying you're
surprised by the opening choice and
fabiano himself right now is surely not
happy with what his little opening
experiment uh where it has gotten him
so we'll see
he'll have to dig deep here anish
clearly
in control we'll come back to this
game but we potentially have quite a big
upset on the cards here
that's right and it's an upset not
because of player strength but because
with the black pieces you don't see
fabiano lose from the white side very
often but as we check out the remaining
games we know we had sam shanklin and
program withdraw and it looks like
vidic's queen went to h8 and then
that duda played f5 defending this pawn
on g7 and by the way magnus and rapport
they don't they don't want to you know
play too many moves it seems like
they're just slowly working through that
position let's quickly go to that
carlson rapport game and catch up with
the last few moves and i was curious
about the time situation so we see now
magnus down to 32 minutes rapport 10
minutes more so 42 minutes we're only on
move 12 robert
yeah they are moving quite slowly here
in this game and the last few moves we
saw b3 instead of castling rapport
played bishop b7 and after the trade on
c4
now magnus had to take with the queen so
i'd mention an idea of knight to d2
trying to win the opponent c4 with the
knight but
just like in um
trying to think of the opening name i'm
just forgetting but there's c3 can be
played here so you give the back pawn
back on your own terms and if the queen
takes now we have the move knight to d5
so then we'd have a fork we don't win
material but we get this bishop on e3
and you'll likely have to take with the
pawns pretty awkward these double pawns
and so that's why magnuson said took
with the queen on c4 so it's precise
choices by both players as if instead
castle had occurred and we've gotten to
this variation with c3 after queen c3
your knight is loose on c6 so there's no
more knight d5 for you so every move
counts
indeed and i mean what a rich position
after queen takes to
queen take c4 we saw richard
throw the knight out
to b4 and robert at first sight the
knight looks like it's moving
in a weird direction but it's all about
that central control and and more
particularly the the square on d5
that's right the knight came back to d5
the bishop moved to g5 and the reason
why it was important to this knight from
c6 to d5 rather than the knight from f6
to d5 is you want to control this e4
square and that's why magnus just played
bishop to g5 is now e4 is a threat in
many different positions the knight
thankfully for black can go to b6 with a
tempo against the queen but if you get
e4 and the knight we're going to move
not to b6 then e5 is the follow-up with
a fork of the bishop and the pin knight
on f6 so this is why the knight from c6
went to d5 and just like we're
mentioning in the duboff yes the panko
game
c5 at some point is what black would
like to go for because these are two
isolated pawns over here on the queen
side and if we can trade the c pawn that
isolate upon it for the very nice
healthy d4 pawn that would be to black's
benefit
i have a question here robert as black
the bishop has just come to g5 where
will it go if i play h6
it's taking
h6 is taking on f6
um so after bishop takes knight takes
it's one of these positions where
black is happy to have the bishop pair
but with these split pawns that's what
gives white some really good chances
well so we will
we will see how does witcher try and
engineer this as c5 liberating push an
interesting game i think both players
will wind up being a very long time at
some point we're only an hour and a half
away from the first time control so
we're gonna take a quick break and we'll
be back with all the action here from
round six shortly
[Music]
so
there are still many rounds remaining
here in tata still chess 2022 but after
this event is done the next huge event
is the feed a grand prix 2022 leg one
begins february 3rd as 24 of the top
players in the world start their fight
for qualification to the 2022 candidates
the fide grand prix features dingley ren
anish giri hikaru nakamura and so many
more they would like to win the grand
prix go to the candidates win that and
have a chance to play magnus carlsen for
the world chess championship a fiona we
saw five games remaining in the round
and five you may say didn't we just have
six
one game just ended as a draw yeah so uh
in the middle of against gwandalio's
game and maybe we can pull that up for
one second we were thinking niels we
like his position here the pawn
structure is weakened but that bishop on
g7 is a monster
but shakira mamidiarov after queen takes
zee for robert
he offered a draw
so i have to say that shakur mama jarob
is just brilliant because he's offered
draws in this tournament when the engine
says it's better when it says the
position's even now he's worse and the
players don't have the engine at their
disposal while they're playing of course
so
niels who has played a nice game thus
far he's like yeah okay it looks about
level and with best play the game
probably should be level however all of
a sudden niels was the one with the
momentum here he drew magnus carlson
yesterday chakra didn't get anything out
of this opening so you know how much i
love the draw for i'm trying to justify
it from mama jaro's perspective this is
not on the players it's on organizers i
believe to ban the draw offer i can only
say it so many times
i think here there's also the added
benefit and you said you know uh uh that
shaq we only saw two of his door for the
one that we were most shocked about
about he was actually on the receiving
end i think of the draw for by by duboff
uh and i think he's used it quite
cleverly he offered against duda in a
position where he was worse
making duda spend some of his time on
the clock and then turning that around
and today and
again in a position that was maybe
slightly inferior and on top of that he
also mentioned in the interview
yesterday he's been suffering uh from a
slight cold
so that might also be playing into it
but shahid mahmoud yaroff here
one of our three leaders he has made a
draw he was made here under a little bit
of pressure but yeah still five very
excited
exciting games remaining
yeah and like i said i don't blame him i
don't play niels i just hope that going
forward draw first aren't allowed and
that would i think make more fighting
chess and we understand from the
player's perspective they're trying to
maximize their chances and what they
feel will help them gain points in the
tournament go up the leaderboard mama
jarv right now he's in first place so he
he's doing well but we have five other
games going so we don't need to talk
about draw first for that much longer
indeed so let's bring back the overview
and um
and you know what maybe we can start
with uh fit it against duda
since vidit is another of the tournament
leaders and
are we having a move repetition there no
let's let's catch up with the action
okay i mean
it looks like a really exciting position
but of course all zeroes all the time
that's how top level chess works when
they play so accurately so vidit started
with the move c6 the rook came to c7 did
not want that pawn to keep going trying
to come after it queen h8 going for mate
f5 played
the queen on d4 protects after queen h7
b4 was played by duda he says i don't
want your pawn on c6 it looks like it
can be captured it is hanging but after
a move like i would say queen
g6 check or queen h5 check
the king
i guess this actually might even force a
draw in many of these positions because
if the king goes to g8 you lose your
rook thanks to this check if your king
goes to f8 the queen goes right back and
even if the king goes to e7 the queen
goes back to h8 so i think we're gonna
see some kind of draw with the queen
going back and forth along the h file
and the king shuffling to protect the
pawn
yeah that's exactly what is happening
now uh after b4 we saw that check on h8
and well exactly those moves that you
were just putting
on
the board and um
we saw the two players there
vidit he's looking relaxed we so see him
so often in the not like this deep in
forward thinking pose
but uh here well it's been a very
interesting very dynamic game with duda
blitzing at everything at the start
uh
but here indeed it's hard to see
how dude i can try what if i
go crazy and try and go for
worried
you he's funny because i could tell
you're like no that's not gonna happen
see i take it back i already saw the
trouble i'm gonna run into
right queen d8
hitting the queen through the king and
if the king protects the queen you lose
the rook for free so you can't move your
king that way which means the only way
to go is f7 you can't take on c6 you'll
get mated or probably you lose your
queen at the very least i don't even
need to see checkmate when i see a way
to win your queen by going rook d7
opening up the contact between the
queens and you take the rook you lose
your queen and lose the game so uh
king f7
back and forth we'll go yeah i think
we will see uh
also this game ending
um in a draw quite soon especially when
looking at with it you kind of know this
game is almost over because
it he's one of the players who we see
very rarely in this kind of with this
kind of demeanor he's usually super
focused
uh but here i think he's figured out
and there's nothing duda can do and he
himself also probably has nothing better
than to to repeat the moves
and duda says more than an hour on his
clock so great preparation by him he
seems to love this opening and he's used
it with success
indeed so well we'll uh keep an eye oh
and there is the move maybe we can stay
here king f7 has just been played
uh i expect
uh veda to to give the check on h5 out
quite quickly or can with it actually
uh deviate here
he can but i think all roads lead back
to the queen coming to h8 because one
tricky little move is queen b8 hoping
that duda won't see the tactics that the
rook c6 queen b7 is check scooping up
the rook on c6 but after the queen comes
back to d6 here now your pawn on c6 is
under attack your rook is pinned so
you'll likely have to go queen h8 back
just to
attack the pawn and then queen d4 and
it's another way to repeat besides king
e7 king f7 and queen h5 h8
okay so well
uh
we see there with it i think that's what
he is thinking about
it gives us the stair into the camera
um but we'll come back
uh here even if that's only now we will
stay because queen h5 has just appeared
on the board just as we were zooming in
some great work by our producer and
and yeah i think
um robert will see a handshake here
alright that king can't go anywhere else
it has to go
to squares like e7 and f8 and for duda
he's not going to take any risk because
you're not obviously not going up to f6
that would be
just pretty ridiculous at this point the
queen would come it's quite g6 or g5 and
g6 looks way better so yeah the king
going to e7 or to f8 because the draw is
the same regardless queen h8 queen h5
so i don't know if we're gonna stay here
wait for young christoph duda or if
we're gonna keep these players on the
camera i suggest we go back to the
overview see what's happening um
elsewhere as the king has just gone back
to
seven
and uh maybe we can say even in the
overview long enough for this this game
to
to conclude that robert what's happening
elsewhere
nothing too surprising in magnus against
report the
and there was he
did it going back to h8 so the draw is
about to be agreed upon um but
yeah here we go king f7 is
it yeah it's just
i'm waiting for them to shake hands now
there it is
the draw agreed between vidit and
duda
and that means that only one of our
co-leaders could take the sole lead but
he is playing on the black side against
magnus carlsen that
that's richard report
an interesting fight between vidit and
duda where duda showed some big
preparation but uh
vitid finding enough active counterplay
and they're analyzing and talking about
variations uh and
duda is kind of coolly saying yep this
move is my response i'm good here but
now it seems that he finally has
something to think about uh but it's
interesting game great preparation by
unchestup duda and for vidit he still
remains tied with mama jarv if
report wins his game
with the black pieces magnus then
rapport will be the sole leader
otherwise vetted after six rounds
remains at the top
yeah absolutely and well we'll have to
see can rapport make a big statement
here with the black pieces but
uh both these uh vetted while continuing
with his very solid performance
um
should we check in with with magnus
carlsen and richard report
okay we can go there and the uh
only other change i see in positions is
the carjacking and von force which we'll
head to in a bit but this position
magnus has given up his bishop you asked
the question what's going to happen if
the pawn goes to h6 i just want to
mention that move e4 looks to win a
piece i mentioned that before
as a way to attack the knight on d5 and
then try to go for the fork but after
knight to b6 here you have a problem
because now e4 is under attack in
addition to the queen being under attack
the only way to protect is queen e2 and
i think tactically this fails for white
because bishop e4 bishop takes f6 great
i remove the guard of your bishop on e4
but i don't have to take on f6 just
because you took me once more you make a
different type of move bishop takes f3
now i hit your queen as well and black
steals a pawn
yeah so those tactics did not work for
magnus so instead of
e4 he went
developed finally the last piece knight
went to d2 and richard report indeed
played h6 asking the bishop what are you
gonna do you had called it robert that
bishop takes on f6
and after the exchange magnus brings
once again the afric 2c1 it's something
it's been a theme of the day a little
bit of which rook to bring where and
maybe you can explain why it was the f
work that came to c1
well you don't really want to put the f
work there but the a3 pawn is loose but
you really want to get the move e4 that
would be great for white so as we think
about this game
sort of holistically and we think about
all across the board what decides one
at some point it's likely that we'll see
a trade of bishops if this you know this
knight moves that would trade the
bishops and without the bishops white
controls the square like c6 black isn't
getting the c5 move so fiona i would say
that even though the eval bar says it's
just level
it doesn't tell the whole story because
white has one weak pawn on a3 and black
still has two even though the bishop on
d6 is defending the c7 pawn so i feel
like in these dynamics it's just easier
to play for white but rapport seems you
know like he's handling this very well
thus far and he's not afraid in the
slightest yeah i would also uh take
white if offered the choice
i think this game is very likely to be
at least influenced by how low the
players are getting on the clock uh
richard report down to 25 minutes minus
just over half an hour but we're still
only on move 16 here so not even halfway
through the moves and maybe we can very
quickly bring up uh the format of this
event and and the time control
it is a very long amount of players get
100 minutes for the first 40 moves then
an extra 50 minutes on move 40 and
finally an extra 15 minutes on move 60
for the rest of the game with increment
a 30 second increment from move one so
move
40 is always the first big goal that the
players have to reach to get the extra
time and here is still 25 moves away
so many moves to make not that much time
for the players
they've been trying to figure out this
position it is level so they're doing a
great job of finding precise choices and
it looks like report i couldn't quite
tell he moved his knight to d7
i wonder why
d5 has has been another theme of the day
with a lot of the players on the black
side looking for that liberating
shot and well if you're magnus how do
you fight against
uh how do you fight against c5
i don't think you can which makes 97 a
great move i wasn't thinking about this
night retreat it's a very good choice
just a half step ago i would have
thought about making move like queen e7
or trying to bring my f rook to c8
things like that but after queen e7
which does attack the pawn on a3 maybe
it gives white just enough time to make
a move like queen c3 and knight c4 and
that makes c5 that much more difficult
because the bishop on d6 will be
threatened so
not a careless move but a move that you
just make because you know it looks like
the right move to play rather than
actually calculating that's how
neutral even positions become worse for
you so knight d7 i really like that
choice
no knight b3 because of bishop d5 of
course there's no knight e4 because the
bishop covers the square so i don't
really see a way that magnets can stop
the move c5 yeah very impressive play so
far by richard report who
with the black pieces have some given
magnus any real chances so far we'll see
how this develops but robert i'm with
you let's uh go back and check in
with uh sergey karyakin and jordan van
ferece
oh gosh well for jordan
you know the event
started well for him with a win then he
lost that end game to report and we're
not in a pure end game there still are
so many pieces on this board but the
queens are off and that's very bad news
for black in this position because
if we go back a few moves to see how the
queens came off at this point right here
we saw g3 was played taking away f4 a4
knight to d2 and it was jordan who said
i will trade queens with you and it
turns out that after the queens came off
the board here and white played b4 which
is a temporary pawn sacrifice
here comes white's pieces to the queen
side and white controls the pawn brakes
fiona so white has to be better
yeah and well uh one of the black pieces
that is still standing on the the rim
that night
on h5 the bishop from c8
both of these pieces are not great right
now and the position opening up will be
bad news for jordan uh indeed it's going
to be very difficult for him here to
keep
things together after king after sergey
played rook
rook to e3
and that's a move that i'm curious about
uh robert
i see that we're defending sort of
defending across the the third rank but
what's what are the ideas behind the
work coming up
rook lifts don't necessarily have to
lead the checkmate that rook is coming
right to a3 and the a4 pawn is going to
be in trouble so these black knights not
doing anything that one
little measly pawn on g3 takes away the
squares right upon three squares away
from a knight dominates it the knight h5
is on the rim and we'll probably have to
go to f6 and white can play rook a3
bishop e2 bishop d1 go right after this
pawn here on a4 and that's the problem
with pushing your pawns advancing them
too far they get overextended and now
you don't have contact with another pawn
maybe if that palmer back on a7 black
could be all right though still worse
with the pawn on a4 you're likely just
going to lose that pawn and white has
all the time in the world
yeah you're in in big trouble here today
sergey karjakin he is still chasing his
first win uh of the event he's on two
out of five he lost one game
two yes panko drew the rest
and today
he is looking on his way this position
is just an absolute nightmare for jordan
who is such a
proactive player this is not going to be
fun for him he's going to have to defend
uh passively but yeah tough task
he's losing a pawn and there's no way to
save this a4 pawn so if he can defend
this game uh it's
not a miracle exactly but
it's kind of getting close to a miracle
territory
yeah so we will come back here uh let's
bring back the overview again
uh maybe we can
go back to to fabiano
against
aneesh
that game is really interesting yeah so
let's go back there
wow and we loved anish's position and
i definitely still do but it feels like
fabiano is getting a bit more play than
he deserves so
if we
as we bring up the board here we see
that
black's pieces heading towards the queen
side but one thing to note is that this
bishop just retreated to uh e7 so there
was an exchange of pawns in a4
black's knights over there on the queen
side but fiona i mean f4 that's the move
that we know fabiano was setting up for
and there it goes yeah it's long last
there is something that white has going
for him
um because well we had talked about how
anish he was in charge of the the queen
side and
now at least there's some counter play
anish how is he going to continue i
guess he is going to continue playing on
the the queen side
once again we've talked about it all day
long i'm looking at that pawn
does that pawn also want to come to c5
it looks like it will
go to c5 either now or in the near
future the a5 pawn can be captured and
it could have been captured before f4
but the last thing that white wants is
to fully open this queen side because
knight takes a5 here there's a problem
tactically speaking uh bishop b4 may be
an option hitting the rook and hitting
the knight but you can also just i
didn't even see bishop before but
knight c5 also makes sense uh you know
at first i was just looking how do i
keep opening the position get this pawn
and black is crashing through along the
queen side and white has nothing to
speak for over on the king side so i
like fabiano's decision to play f4 and
your move c5 still very tempting here
for black because if you take a5 you
will lose the a4 pawn right after so c5
makes perfect sense to me
if not c5
how do we deal with with the pawn on on
a5 what are the pieces as black that you
feel
if i look at this position i kind of
like black but i also feel a lot of the
pieces could
be improved at the same time i'm not
entirely sure where i want them
to jump to the knight
on the rim on a6
is that a knight that we want to keep to
potentially jump into b4 do we want to
exchange it do we want to go knight c5
anish he decided uh well let's bring the
queen up at the moment on d7 you might
be wondering what's it doing there but
again it looks down at the pawn
on a4
it also covers the f5 square or so it
may seem but the evaluation bar is just
creeping up in fabiano's favor the last
few moves have been good for him and
that's no surprise we can explain it
quite logically white's last moves
here in this game were to play f4 trying
to play f5 and just because you put
another piece to stop f5 doesn't make
the move impossible and after f5 e takes
f5 i'm even thinking can i push this
pawn to e6 can i play bishop h3 go after
this pawn on f5 and it's really an
unclear battle now but at least white
has much more play to speak of and isn't
just getting dominant on the queen side
with nothing to do all of a sudden black
needs to be very careful rook coming to
f1 if this knight moves out of the way
maybe the pawn goes up to e6 this knight
coming to d4 we could see so many
possibilities here for fabiano and i
think this is really a key moment now in
the game will fabiano sense his chance
f5
i mean it is giving up upon of course
it's easier for us we must say it every
day to throw f5 in there and worry about
that later fabiano he is gonna have to
put a lot more thought into it um if he
gives up the pawn will there be a
sufficient compensation what will the
the counter play what will the play look
like uh but it it very much feels like
the tide is turning
uh and i would love to see f5 appear on
the board
i'm going to put you on the spot do you
think fabian was going to play them with
f5 yes
yeah i think so
i i feel like you know he's fully aware
both players are that if white does
nothing black is just better and i think
anish played the move queen d7 because
he thinks that f5 is impossible but
again just because
one two three pieces cover a square
that's only defended by one knight that
doesn't mean you can't make the move and
it's a pawn sacrifice that gives white
something to attack if you don't play f5
now black is going to continue playing
on the queenside maybe it's c5 with a4
hanging or c5 c4 so we can see how
direct the plan is for black and there's
robert
wow
you were right
i mean i'm i'm very happy to see the
move i
it wasn't the most
testing of questions i mean basically
what the question was do you think
fabiano will make the best move so it's
easy for me to be like yes i think he
will
but uh no it's great uh to see it we saw
anish immediately we captured the other
question i was going to ask you is it
too slow if we prepare f5 by playing g4
but i think well fabiano has answered it
by playing f5 immediately and now it'll
be very curious i'll be curious to see
how does he proceed from here uh
pressurizing the pawn on f5 do we first
bring the rook to the file the queen
and it's another good question i made
bishop h3 just because the first movie
came to mind uh but i could see rook f1
being the better choice and
you know you say the question was
whether or not he finds the best move
but one of the things about fabiano is
that he doesn't make speculative
sacrifices other players in this field
are more likely to make a sacrifice
based on their feel their intuition
whereas fabiano if he's going to
sacrifice material oftentimes it's best
because he's calculated a follow-up but
right now we see that he hasn't made a
next move so his
study his strength has led him to
believe effect is the best move he makes
that move quickly and now he recognizes
that there is a lot that a niche has to
be concerned about and now he's going to
find the correct follow-up is it rook f1
is it queen f3 is it bishop h3 all moves
are possible here
knight to d4 not on the question either
but i would refrain from playing knight
d4 just for the moment because that
piece can be kicked from the square and
f5 is defended so bishop h3 or rook f1
seems to pile up more pressure without
giving black a way to immediately do
something about it and i think even from
the camera you can tell that the tide
has turned a little bit here fabiano
earlier to me didn't seem too happy
now we see him full focus i think he is
sensing that suddenly from a position
where anish was the one in control
things have changed and anish looking a
little bit less happy to my eye
well he i wonder if he
thought that f5 was prevented because if
he played queen d7 which i'm pretty sure
he did with the idea of stopping f5 and
then it happens anyway that can be
deeply uncomfortable for a player and i
mean
hunching over the board here he is uh
like his
mouth was about to make a move for his
pieces like whispering to them it's like
come on queen you can do it you can
protect the f5 pawn you're going to save
my position but fiona it really does
seem like you're right that all of a
sudden that fabiano he's upright he's
like looking he's ready to pounce and
anish is like oh this could be trouble
for me
yeah i mean if we compare this position
that we have on the board to if we go
back um let's say five six moves to
where anish played the move b5 here it
was uh all play for black no fun for
white it didn't look like there was any
uh counter play and yeah funny anish was
the one having all the fun and with
every move fabiano uh improved his
pieces a little bit then uh defending
here on a4
a few clever moves and then came this
f45 push and it happened
so quickly somehow
it's one of these
games where if you're
quickly going through it you know after
the round is over you don't have the
engine on like okay this looked normal
this look normal and then you're like
wait a second how did white get a better
position uh i sometimes do that when i'm
just checking games on my phone where i
i'm like wait let's go back that looks
really good for black and now it looks
really good for white so was i
mis-evaluating or did something happen
where a player
wasn't
playing necessarily in the spirit of the
position and i think that anish who was
playing so well to this point he made
his move first bishop e7 a retreating
move and then queen d7 which had the
purpose of stopping white's play
and then we see f5 happen e takes a five
and he goes queen to f3 fiona following
it up uh by putting pressure on the f5
pawn and white's pieces have come to
life
indeed and uh well
this one
really coming to life now also here
today i think we'll have quite a bit of
time trouble action because
uh we are in move 25 the players are
around the 25 minute mark 15 moves to
make still and not that's a lot of moves
in this position we're back in the
overview
and uh robert maybe we can check in with
daniel lubov and andre yessipanko
although before we do isn't this the
bathtub formation like the
the pawn structure
very well spotted i believe it is indeed
for those of you who aren't sure what
robert is talking about
um look at the four words remaining they
they do form a bathtub robert will also
hear from
from duda uh in in just a second so
there is uh let's go there
young christoph you just played a draw
with philip it was a very sharp game and
looking at the time management it looked
like a very impressive opening
preparation from your side
yeah indeed
i mean more of the game was my
preparation but um
yeah i mean many uh semitaroth lines i
mean the preparation goes to i mean 25
or even 13 moves sometimes so
um
yeah actually
i surprised my opponent and with this
line also kind of
could couldn't recall like all the
details
um
yeah and after knight d frequent d6
actually
my knowledge ended
um after that knight c5 was i mean i'm
not sure if it was the best or not but
um it was very practical i guess for
white because in this uh
in this end game i mean with rooks and
queens after rookie c5 okay i was maybe
pressing a bit but
why it should be active enough
i guess to hold draw and um
yeah but
i think i played decently
but
also played this before kind of stupid
move i mean i thought it was like the
only
uh the only move to have a game but i
mean it was some absurd actually and i
could have just taken on c6 i think and
there was some wrong game maybe drop
down but um
i mean there were some postpones you
know some some races and so on so it was
anyone's game i think but i was ahead of
one hour in the on the clock so
that
yeah would have made more sense i guess
um you're at 50 in the tournament after
six rounds um are you happy or satisfied
with the results so far no
i'm hardly happy um
i actually
i mean i sparred of course
my game against majoro
which i could probably should have won
but
instead i mean i did harakiri and and
that's why i'm on zero actually uh score
not plus two or plus one even
so um yesterday was also very crazy game
against korea king but uh most of the
time i was
worse or less so
okay draw in the end wasn't uh wasn't
that bad i guess
yeah still there are many rounds to play
so anything can happen basically
yeah cause like yesterday when i checked
for a game with karjakin in the final
position you're plus two somehow like
can you explain what
i mean i mean
i mean yeah we both asses position
correctly and to be to be a draw after
some repetition and he played 96 97
which was one way of
repeating the position but then he
wanted to be fancy and play rook g4
which felt very natural um for me as
well and
yeah and it was
i mean the move container hall and i was
just winning after you gave one but i
just spotted you know earlier that after
bishop e3 is also repetition
so i even didn't look you know for
something better because i was also
insane
so um yeah that was very annoying of
course uh to see that i mean rogue one
wasn't like the most difficult move in
the world so um was pretty annoying also
also the fact that he you know repeated
this twice i mean played rook g7 could
have played rook g8 with uh frequent
repetition after bishop h6 but played
rook g7 they could have still win by
means of rugby one second time but i
just didn't see it
does this position come through your
mind at night when you're when you're in
bed and just thinking like oh like
rook f1
no i mean of course it's annoying but
also i think sergey clearly missed his
position earlier on i was in bad shape
also
also also taking into consideration time
so
now i think it's
okay i just wanted to restart you now
and in the opening because i was uh i
mean could it have been the opening
couldn't have been like uh forcing
like guests i guess so um
yeah i just
burn a lot of time and then
also misplayed my very fancy idea i came
up with over the board and
yeah but i mean
i mean when you are out of form or maybe
not playing perfectly then i mean
sometimes uh such things happen so um
okay overall i think it's like kind of
fair enough for a result
um last month you played the
rotarapton blitz in your home country
you finished second in the blitz
how is just in poland or the popularity
of chess in poland and
and what happened the days after uh the
championships
yeah the popularity is
clearly growing but also i think is the
worldwide phenomenon not strictly in
poland
um partially thanks to
netflix theory queen's gambit which is
extremely popular or used to be
extremely popular in poland
um partially due to my results also
when i mean there were no
i mean there was cavity and uh there
weren't like many
uh many successes in other disciplines
then i mean i happened to know to break
uh magnus carson world record of not
releasing games and so on and it was
very like popular
also in
even mainstream polish media so
yeah just really getting more and more
popular
and also we had this world rapid and
this
championship was kind
of extraordinary to be honest like no
one expected it ever
to happen so he was of course very cool
and
yeah and i
played very well i think rapid but
didn't deliver in the last round against
satoru
who
played i mean for the for the first
place i mean if i had one i would be on
his spot i guess
playing against emponyachi but and but i
played i mean
quite quite decently
in rapid and play terribly in bliss but
somehow you know one
on too many games and
i mean i mean that's uh
yeah i was winning you know a bunch of
games in a row which was crucial on the
second day and somehow you know happened
to share also um i mean this time to
sharing first and second and what was
[Music]
nvr so
um yeah it was crazy uh and crazy
crazy days and but also i mean you know
it's
somehow like i wasn't playing in poland
yeah i mean it was so different you know
because i'm usually i mean i've played
wardrobe in the blitz you know several
times in
many countries many continents you know
and somehow it's i didn't value
particularly that i'm like in poland but
there were many fans like uh perhaps too
many
because and you were voted like the
third best sportsman in poland is that
correct or like there was like this
sports gala with no no i wasn't seeing
top 15. i mean i wasn't uh qualified to
this but okay
yeah
but um
but you're getting more famous now in in
poland i assume yeah yeah now it was
olympic area and you know it's highly
important i guess in sports in general
also so we have many
many good at least i mean
many many middles only picks so um
yeah i mean but i just want you to
talk about this chance in poland and
that certainly be like you know in
mainstream media because i don't
particularly enjoy it okay thank you so
much thanks
always great to hear from duda who's
taking everything with this mod was
funny to hear him about talking about
his the harakiri he committed against
mamedyarov
robert we still have four games going on
here in round six and maybe you can very
quickly tell us what your expectations
in each are before we go on a quick
break
third report it is even material
opposite-colored bishops but most
importantly the a4 pawn was on a3 that's
going to march up the board and the
bishop on f3 covers the queening square
so rook will have difficulty fending it
off in the top right corner with daniel
duvall against andre esopenko still
better for dubai he's a knight on a
light square against the dark sword
bishop the pawn on c6 is weak the one
thing that andre can count on is some
pressure against the e4 pawn so from the
black side he has some hope bottom left
five under caruana has anish giri in the
think tank and we have him on screen
it's not going to be easy for him to
figure out what to do after queen f3 and
piling up the pressure on the f5 pawn he
thought he had it covered not so fast
and finally last but not least sergey
karjakin he is doing a great job of
putting all his pieces
on
the
on the fly against the a4 pawn first the
rook on a3 then the knight came back to
c3 he pushed his pawn to b5 to stop the
bishop on d7 from defending it the
bishop will come back to d1 and finally
at long last white will win upon and
likely go on to win this game in my
opinion
so tree draws so far but wide pressing
in every remaining game will come back
here in just a minute don't go anywhere
because we're less than an hour away
from the first time control
[Music]
do
welcome back to our coverage of round
six of the tata steel chess masters this
year unfortunately the amateurs couldn't
play here alongside their grandmasters
because of
the local
corona restrictions but the great news
is you can get involved you too can take
part in our online amateur tournaments
there are three tournaments to choose
from you can play all three if you
wanted if you want to
tomorrow we will have a rapid event
starting at 2 30 local time that's
central european time
and then on sunday two more events
starting with a blitz event three plus
two and also one personal at one plus
nil bullet events and that will be fun
you can join for free to sign up head to
chess.com slash club slash tata still
jester and you see the link at the
bottom and there will be prizes for the
top three finishes so we are hoping to
see you many of you take part and robert
for now back to the action here uh in
round six where we've had three draws
but we could just see every other game
and decisively
yeah my first question is can i join
those tournaments i really want to win
those signed chess boards funny that
whenever i go to a tournament those top
players they never sign my boards but we
have had three draws here four games
still remaining and as we look from
board to board we could even get four
decisive games
i mean it's crazy uh white is pressing
in every single one
of the games one of the game where the
bar has uh swung a lot in white's favor
since we left it is magnus carlsen
against richard report so we could start
there
yes and look at this a4 pawn it's a
passer there's a rook behind the past
pawn that's always a good thing the
bishop covers the promoting square and
black's best move and maybe d4 back to
d5 can't get away with that can't close
the diagonal and that means that white
is ready to walk the pawn up the board
and there's very little it seems that
black can do about it for the time being
and this d4 pawn can be captured so so
much available to white here fiona this
is not looking good for a port and he
doesn't have much time either no and i
mean this is a game that's very strange
i was having a quick look during the
break if we just go back one move
before a4
richard's last move was a move that the
computer didn't approve of queen e7
but it's really hard for me to
understand why i and i think my
follow-up question is i'm surprised that
this position should be equal because it
already looked uh very difficult for
black
right because if black does nothing
there's going to be a problem the a pawn
is just going to march forward that
seems quite straightforward so with that
in mind it looks like report had to play
the move knight e5 trying to take this
bishop and if the bishop moves then
strike with d3 now it's not nearly as
simple as just equal and it's actually a
complicated line some of these positions
may require at least a temporary pawn
sacrifice with pawn to d3 and you're
just banking on activity to hold black
in this game because d3 pawn takes d3
you just gave a pawn away didn't you but
now f5 is the strike hitting the bishop
trying to get this pawn on d3 and things
are still a mess d4
pawn takes bishop pawn takes knight
bishop takes and then we get a position
that is sort of reminiscent of the
yesapanko duboff game or duval vesa
panko i should say when duke has the
knight against the bishop and this looks
bad for black but when you're armed with
an engine and you know that it should be
level then it's
then you know that black is doing okay
but at first glance it still looks like
white is doing well yeah and good luck
finding that engine less at the board
with only around 15 minutes on the clock
so we're not gonna
judge richard too harshly of course but
in the game after now queenie seven
magnus played a4 as the moves are coming
in a bit faster
rook d8 and well magnus he has just gone
and captured that pawn on d4 he is now
a pawn up and not just any old pawn
robert
it just has the looks of a
pretty clean path forward from here what
rapport's gonna do is he's probably
gonna try to play bishop c5 next and
drum up some counter play and the bishop
on c5 can at some point retreat to a7 to
block the pawns progress because we know
what white's next moves want to be a5 a6
a7 a8 and it really is not going to be
easy to stop
absolutely not uh
magnus must be a huge favorite to win
the game here
which would make him join the leaders
and we would probably have a four-way
tie
at the top uh let's go back to the
overview one more time i was seeing in
the chat i think the clock will play a
decisive role in almost all our
remaining games but maybe especially so
in the game between fabiano and anish
let's go
back there
the bar
in this game it's been everywhere robert
it was all the way down
giving black a huge advantage then it
liked fabiano after his f45 and now
it's back and just giving zeroes
the last three moves knight c5 by anish
trying to attack his a4 pawn so we see a
trade and after bishop takes c5 here
five mana played d4 he did not want
anish to capture on e3 remove one of his
attackers the f5 pawn but that move not
approved of by the engines so d4 to my
eyes looks like a very natural move but
it does give black the c4 square and i
think that's the major point that if the
bishop retreats to helping the king
become safer after bishop h3 you're just
about ready to win this pawn and black
does not want to play this move g6 as
you see after g4 white is just crushing
so
after
so after d4
yeah the bishop should come back here
and
i think it's all about this knight c4
jump
and are you ready here so let's see
knight c4
at first i would be
tempted to just capture it
capture the knight
and now
extra pawn right probably it is an extra
pawn and i don't have enough
slave
i guess here can i target the pawn on f5
if i go
rook f1 but no i i guess it's all very
slow already i would like to make a few
moves i would like to play c3 stabilize
i'd like to attack f4 but uh f5 sorry
but yeah
it looks like i'm just not in time
yeah unfortunately uh if you're looking
this from white switch like the rook
comes to b8 very quickly and it just
seems like black is well ahead so this
move knight c4 giving up that square it
may not seem like you know it doesn't
stop me i could take on f5 because my
thread is knight takes h6 check so it
still looks very worrisome for a niche
there's a queen in line with a bishop
there's a rook behind it and that means
there are sacrifices on h6 that you have
to consider so i understand why fabi did
it if there's a way out here for a niche
and clearly there is based on the
evaluation bar i don't know what the
best path forward is i mean this is such
a dangerous position so that's why
sometimes you make these choices for as
far managers did he is trying to
just attack attack attack and actually
look at anish's last move d4 he went
bishop e7 which has to be a worse
version because after bishop h3 now if
you try knight c4 after knight takes f5
this bishop is hanging knight takes h6
is still a threat and there are problems
down the diagonal
there are problems down in the diagonal
there are problems on the clock as well
give me only five minutes on the clock
we only move uh well this was move 28
bishop h3
and now indeed
some problems and knight c4 might still
be the best move we see anish getting
ready
who
he's just kindly going to defend the
pawn on f5 i think i think he's just g6
oh no that is not good news for him and
what fabiano did is he's putting
pressure on f5 all across the board and
as you keep talking about most
importantly on the clock so the reason
why he went d4 and did it quickly is
he's using time as a weapon if he gave a
niche that's like 10 minutes to think by
sitting do i want to play d4 do i have
another move to play then anish would
have been able to make a follow-up come
up with a clear plan and strategy but
now a nice place g6 the bishop on h7 is
an awful piece and g4 is the first move
that comes to mind because you're trying
to blast open the position and this king
on g8 is going to feel the heat robert
you asked me earlier did i think uh
fabiano was going to play a
f5 do you think fabiano is going to play
g4 yeah for sure
there's no way he doesn't play that move
i can't think of an alternative that
makes sense
g4 just feels extremely obvious because
you're just trying to open up the entire
board here and i think if
g4 is played anish probably has to make
him like f4
because if you take on g4 you're about
to see it there it goes knight takes g4
threatens h6 threatens discoveries
against this queen and the rook behind
it like knight f6 the f7 pawn is in
danger and white is just cruising so
that's why f4 is going to be played to
shut things down and then you don't have
to take you can play g5 and attack the
queen attack the rook
i mean g4 looks so promising
for fabiano and i think he's taking some
time maybe all ready to prepare a
follow-up move i will come back here but
uh fabiano now clearly the one in
control
and um he's on 50 so he will be looking
to get two plus one let's go back to the
over if you see what is happening
elsewhere
from the bar and maybe we can check in
there it looks like yes panko is doing a
great job uh holding holding things
together against in a difficult position
against daniel duboff
he certainly is it looked really
difficult for him before but his last
move was a tactical strike he is giving
up his rook you give one to get one and
right here after rook takes on c6 it
looks like white is
taken upon maybe trying to win this game
here but brook takes a2 a really nice
shot because after queen takes a2 then
there's the move rook takes c6 it's just
a rook trade and if you take this rook
on e6 the queen can capture back here
and this brook is defended and that's
bad news for white because the f2 pawn
will be lost
very impressive stuff by jesse panko i
don't know if we have time to go back to
to where we left it off because we
thought uh duboff was pressing and
things looked very complicated
for yasipanko he put the king
into safety and then the strike in the
center e4 and f5
yeah i mean this move here knight f3
sorry
you're all good we have the established
we establish a knight on a light square
against a bishop on dark squares but i
like what yesapanko did he just went
rookie if you take me i just take back
i'm happy to make that trade now and he
used his activity he makes love for the
king so he's now background checkmates
and then he went bishop c7 bishop b6 and
he sort of forced doubt's hand and now
we're seeing
mass simplification and
white still has some outside hope of
using the light squares against a dark
square bishop but black has this outside
past pawn fiona so i don't really think
that there's much hope for duboff to win
this game no i don't think so either and
uh once again yes panko one of the
youngest players in the field showing
great resilience great maturity and very
very impressive stuff we'll move on uh
from here
and uh maybe we can go to jordan uh ron
forest who's defending
tough position against sergey karjakin
and his apon is gone
his a pawn is gone his knights are still
very bad he has no space for any of his
pieces because of the pawn structure
with all these pawns forward here the
one thing that could go wrong for white
is if somehow the whole position gets
locked up so for instance a move like g4
could not be a good choice because you
close down the king side over here and
you already see the evaluation is going
down the reason why is this knight is
going to get to b7 and to a5 so you go
knight h6 knight f7 knight d8 knight b7
and you stop the pawn push to a5 and i
think black does have all that time to
accomplish that so g4 was an
intentionally bad move to show you how
you can't focus your entire energy on
one side of the board so having h4
for later in the game is really
important so if this knight were to be
on a5 white could still try to punch
through on the king side so
here
it looks like you can play bishop h5 if
the knight moves then play h4 and play
on both flanks if you're white yeah
maybe let's quickly show why we can't go
h4 immediately without any preparations
because then black would be able to
capture and suddenly there's a square
that isn't defended any longer and white
doesn't of course want the black knight
to land on therefore that's why uh
rotowood was suggesting bishop ih5 in
the current position to to kick that
knight and prepare
the h4 push
you always need to look at the
consequences of a pawn move and so the
g3 pawn very important it is dominating
the knight that's three scores away and
we have the potential of a pass pawn but
we don't have a pass pawn quite yet if
this pawn we're on a6 we feel like okay
black can't really afford to put all the
pieces over on the king side but with
the pawn still on a4 the only way to
break through is with a5 and then white
will need to be able to make that break
and protect the square so uh h4 is
rushed instead i like leading with a
move like bishop h5 and black is going
to need to keep this knight here on g6
and white in the meantime to play knight
b3 and with the bishop out the way bring
the rook over to a1 and push for a5
speaking of rush there is absolutely no
rush here for sergey karjakin because
they have made move 40 so the players
have gotten the extra 15 minutes so we
will move on from here and for the next
half hour we will mostly be focusing on
the three games where a time situation
is playing a huge role but magnus
carlsen he might not be needing much
more time that pawn
is
advancing as steadily robert
pawns on a5 it can go to a6 right now do
not take this knight on b6 because if
you take on b6 down goes your rook on a2
that's the entire point and white is
still better after losing a rook for a
knight because of this past pawn going
to b7 so i wouldn't advocate for a takes
b6 but if you were to make a mistake
that's how good magnus's position is to
begin with he will not
take the knight but he can and still be
ahead so i could put the pawn on a6 i
could leave the tension here um but it's
a matter of time it feels like before
white is
is going to push that pawn to the other
side completely
yeah there's one move i was curious
about here i was wondering can i go
maybe queen e3
try and pin the knight but
i realize then i'm still not not really
threatening to take it
i thought i might just try and tie you
down a little bit further
it looks like a great move i mean black
can barely do anything at all here in
fact knight c8 doesn't even work and
knight c tries to protect the queen
because of tactics yes your knight is
defending the queen but i can remove the
guard and it
you don't move your queen you lose your
queen on a7 and if you take on e3 i will
not take you back
yet i will take on d8 with check and
only then take your queen and white
steel is a knight in a rook and wins the
game so your queen e3 move fiona is
fantastic
we need three is hunting but there are
plenty other uh tempting options as well
magnus
is considering his choices but it looks
like
he is going to get the full point here
today uh against swisher's report
and it was
you know an inaccuracy by report that
led to a rough position and that's
sometimes how chess goes especially when
you're playing magnus carlsen you're
even according to the evaluation bar but
you're uncomfortable and magnus is the
best at punishing you for your mistakes
robert we are going to take a final just
a couple minutes break before we lead
into the the final time scramble and
we'll keep the camera and the board on
magnus carlsen so we'll be right back
[Music]
we are back with
uh the decisive uh one of the decisive
parts of round six here in vikenzi and
magnus carlson has indeed played the
move queen e3 pinning the bishop
uh pinning the knight along that
diagonal and richard report has answered
with bishop to e7
plays bishop e7 because the
rook on a2 is still a little bit loose
here so you can't take on b6 just yet
but magnets trying to figure out a way
can i just defend my rook in which case
the knight is under attack like rook c1
to c2 but fiona your move queen a3 is a
great one i think it simplifies matters
and doesn't give report any chances to
mix things up
yeah and i really like your suggestion
of
rook c at 2c2
and it's hard to see what what black's
follow-up is going to be
because you actually can't play knight
c8 still right like rook c2 knight c8
rook takes c8 once more you take the
queen on e3 rook takes d8 is still check
and then after bishop takes pawn takes
queen white is a piece ahead still with
a past pawn and magnus he is not
stressed he's only got nine minutes on
the clock but it's not a problem in this
situation he knows that all is required
uh is one or two good moves it doesn't
even have to be the best moves to be
honest
uh because that's just how overwhelming
uh his position is it is an extra pawn
black is completely tied down so this
one is close close to over here
i think reports hoping for one last
effort here is that after rook c2 bishop
g5 if magnus were to rush with pawn
takes b6 black has this move queen takes
a2 giving up the queen for a rook after
rook takes a2 bishop e3
pawn takes e3
now the rook takes on b6 and we have a
rook for two minor pieces and all the
pawns on the same side of the board so
even though white is much better it may
not be the simplest position to win and
it is probably still winning but it's
one of these situations you don't want
to get into if you're magnus you want to
be a bit precise so after rook c2 if
bishop g5 is in fact played i think the
queen will just go to c5 attack the rook
the knight is still under attack the
queen is going to be in trouble so
i think this is just what's going to end
the game yeah i'm maintaining all the
threats also rook c to c2 had the
advantage not only did
that move defend the rook on a2 but also
the knight
on d2 so absolutely everything on the
control here
for magnus
um
while for richard
well two minutes
on the clock we're only still on move 26
but i think this isn't even going to
reach move 30 i think we'll um
we'll see a resignation here
yeah right even right now i can see it
happening he may just play bishop g5
it's the only move he has because as we
mentioned knight c8 there's a rook takes
c8 and rook takes d8 is check very
importantly so white would win a piece
and bishop g5 queen to c5 and just to go
down this line one last time if flag
tries bishop e7 there's a big difference
now after a takes b6 the queen is under
attack twice so you don't just want to
take white's queen the queen a2 there's
queen takes e7 which is really important
because there's still the dynamic of a
rook for black for two minor pieces but
this pawn is still on the board so if
the queen takes c2 queen takes d8 is
check the king moves and then you can
just play pawn to v7 and it's protected
by the bishop the knight is protected by
the queen white is just winning
even if it wasn't defended by the bishop
the group couldn't capture the pawn on
b7 because there's also a bishop e4
check
on the horizon so it's really all
falling apart here for for black
that's right so uh
it looks like reporting he only has
45 seconds at this point
so
yeah i think we can stay here and see
what richard uh is going to play me i
don't know can we get a zoom in on the
clock to confirm that the times are
correct but i suspect they are we're
only 20
20 minutes away from the time control
so that does make
it does make sense and richard has just
made a move
and it is indeed bishop
g5 so this last attempt that you were
talking about
and um i indeed suspect magnus to just
go queen
c5
that's right and we actually are seeing
that the game between duba villasapanko
is finishing up it's going to be a draw
by repetition so
that game is going to be a split point
we see it on the top right hand side of
the screen
it's over and
duboff gave up his knight and then he
just checked in h5 and e8 and that
couldn't be stopped
so a great hold by andrey yasipanko and
meanwhile magnus has gone receded to
russian players they are just putting
back to pieces
very impressive defensive effort by and
uh by andreas penko magnus has gone
queen c5 richard has responded by
dropping the bishop back to e7
asking the queen what are you going to
do but robert now we are in this line
here
sorry sorry go ahead
we're white i think can just capture on
b6
yeah no he's going to do that and max is
doing the right thing here he's not
rushing the decision he knows it's
winning uh he 100
he knows it's going to be winning but
why
make a rush decision and then regret it
he'll think call calculate he'll triple
check and then he will in fact play a
takes b6 and there he goes i think that
a knight has just disappeared
off at the board so a takes b6 has been
played
and
um
well
black has nothing here we can show that
line one more time if you take the queen
on c5 then you just lose a piece
so richard is trying to take on a2
instead but now this line you showed us
just a second ago queen takes e7
has been played and um everything is
just going to fall apart here richard
will probably try to capture
on c2
but after queen takes d8 and upon
landing on the seventh rank
that will be that
yes this is really just a matter of when
is the handshake going to happen because
magnus carlsen is going to win this game
and he's going to be tied for the lead
fiona it feels like and we haven't
spoken that much about magnus which is
surprising because it's magnus carlson
but he's about to jump to plus two
indeed he's had for his standards a slow
slide but he hasn't lost the game and we
know uh he can just start winning uh
games on command pretty much at any
point so he will be joining the
the leaders and queen takes c2 has just
appeared
on the board
magnus will capture
on d8
only move king h7
and well we expect
b7
and uh
end this game to to be over shortly
maybe robert i don't know if we keep the
players on camera or not but we should
uh go back i believe to to fabiano
carrana and anish giri where
where fabiano took
quite a bit of time but in the end he
did go g4
he did and anish responded with f4 and i
can understand
why 500 was spending so much time
because after queen takes f4 and the
move g5 the bishop on h3 looks very
silly because the pawn on g4 can't move
as you see based on the evaluation bar
it says that black is doing fine so he
went g5 himself and after the queen
moved he decided to take this rook over
here on c8 which is not the best choice
you win material but you lose some of
your edge instead knight g4 not an easy
move to play of course you're going for
the enemy king uh and from here it's i
don't see why this is so advantageous
this pawn on g5 can be captured it's two
extra pawns for black but white is
aiming his pieces towards black's king
the bishop 187 is particularly terrible
yeah i think it's completely
understandable that fabiano instead of
this decided let me just cash in
immediately and there is the resignation
by a richard report after magnus's move
b7 and what a game by magnus i mean it
looked like
nothing for the longest time
and suddenly it just went from nothing
to winning in an instant
that's what happens if you don't play
with extreme care and accuracy against
magnus carlsen he can just win
these positions out of nowhere and
report seems disappointed but it's a
typical magnus type of game
where he just showed the better chess
today
yeah and it was a nice touch there
richard had already kind of left and
magnus started putting back the pieces
so richard rushed back to the void to
also put his
pieces back and yeah magnus as you said
he has joined the leader and i'm sure
we'll be hearing uh from him shortly for
now let's go back to fabiano's game
against aneesh
there's not much time it's essentially a
blitz game until move 40 this was only
30 first move pawn takes e3 so just to
show that instant replay the rook on c
was captured instead of capturing back
aneesh takes this knight he doesn't want
that knight to hop into squares like g4
it's attacking his king and now i'm
wondering do i need to move the bishop
can i make this move pawn e6 to go after
the king and then i'm noticing the queen
on a7 is perfectly placed in some of
these lines to defend the seventh rank
yeah so what you're saying i guess this
is after e6 i don't even have to react
to that i could potentially just move
the bishop from e7 and well that bishop
from e7 it's looking at a pawn on g5
which is undefended and
i mean this game robert i don't know
what to predict all three results
possible here we are only on move 31 so
still nine moves to be played from
either side and i think we'll see a lot
more clearly here after we've made uh
move 40 but it's going to be an intense
15 minutes for the players
i think fabian was in trouble i think if
he doesn't find whatever the sequence is
that keeps the
balance here he's the one in rough shape
because this pawn on e3 is going to
remain there after bishop takes g5 and
if you try to bring your bishop to c1 in
comes this knight to c4 we see that
except for the bishop on h7 black's
pieces are coming to life and right now
if we do a quick material count right
black has seven pawns white has
only six and if you take this that's
gonna be two pawns and a knight for a
rook and that pong e3 is a really really
good pawn
and i mean this game here between the
two players has been such a back and
forth
and
i think i agree with you uh anish after
being better he's handled the pressure
that fabiano was
putting on really well and
yeah now
what
what will be fabiano's
next move such a crucial moment here
he can drop this bishop back to g4 and
then bishop takes g5 that's the worries
you're going to lose this pawn on g5 and
i'm not sure how you're going to get
this pawn because
after bishop g4 bishop takes g5 i
mentioned that bishop c1 looks great
you're going to try to go for the pawn
but in comes this knight to c4 it's an
outpost it's defending e3 d4 is now
under attack and i don't see what white
is doing on the king side so fabinho did
just move he played e6 and i think anish
sort of has to take on g5 and
i'm liking the look of this for black
yeah suddenly black's uh pieces all
coming to life and what looked like a
great great attack for fabiano suddenly
after bishop takes g5 and is that what
anish has played yes it is
we were liking all those those uh pawn
pushers on the king side f4 f5 g4 but
suddenly the pawns are all gone and look
at this black
pawn wall that is suddenly facing
uh
the black king the bishop on h7 right
now it is not doing much but if we
imagine the bishop from g5 moving and
black playing g5 himself
fabiano's king could also find himself
in a lot of trouble and i'm looking
especially at that square on e4
yeah it's been living a lie there's
nothing inside bring this bishop back to
life i see where you're going with that
evanescence would be proud the king on
h1 is in some danger if this pawn can be
removed from g6 but
yeah this is really anyone's game at
this point if queen takes f7 we get into
an end game where it doesn't really feel
like an end game because so much
material is there bishop b7 hits the
rook hits the pawn the game goes on but
i have to imagine that black's activity
and pawn on e3 has to be nice for a
niche
for sure i mean anish's pieces here
would suddenly all be coming
to life
the knight from b6 which isn't doing
much i think as you highlighted that is
looking to jump into c4 as soon as
possible but it might just be uh
the lesser evil for fabiano to go into
the the end game because if you keep the
queens on the board
as i said i think the white king might
be the one that's in more trouble but uh
fabiano he goes bishop d7 and we see
the bar not happy at first with that
move
but it makes sense because you cut the
queen off on the seventh rank and where
did anish just go he took on e6
okay
uh so opening up things fabiano
recaptured and i guess the king is just
gonna go and hide uh in the corner on h8
um maybe there's something to be said
for king g7 as well
king g7 does make sense i guess after
king g7 you have to watch out for some
kind of rook f1 queen f7 potentially but
that would just be a queen trait and the
king can later tuck itself in h8 yeah so
anish he decides to go into the corner
uh he's on a trade
and
i mean
look at this position suddenly the black
pieces that pawn on e3 is such a
thorn in
fabiano's sides
his bishop on b2 isn't playing um the
rook on a1 hasn't moved yet suddenly and
look at anise pieces the knight from b6
will jump into b4 the queen will
suddenly get activated from a7 it's
looking then both at d4 and along the
seventh rank
so
fabiano is suddenly in big trouble here
he is and this game is going to come
down to the wire because of the time
trouble
if this were move
40 already we'd say that anish really
has the advantage we can see the
evaluation bar off the side of the
screen here and
until you reach before you don't feel
comfortable so how can fabiano make
anisha's life difficult what kind of
moves h4 is always a temptation because
you're attacking the bishop and if the
bishop takes then you get the e3 pawn
but in this situation after bishop takes
h4 you can take on e3 with the rook the
knight comes into c4 the bishop's under
attack the rook's under attack and black
is just doing super super well
yeah it's a tough one h4 a tempting move
but maybe here just doesn't quite work
for those of you in the church wondering
what move we're on we're on move 34 so
six moves still to be played for both
players two both of them down to only
two minutes
yeah fabiano needs a good move now can
we try and put pressure on the pawn on
e3
we'd really love to get rid of that is
bishop c1 a move
bishop c1 yes but then the knight still
comes into c4
so
pretty not a pre-move right this is an
online chess but knight c4 at least
mentally can be a kind of pre-move can i
in some lines can i consider giving back
the exchange for the pawn on e3 not
really something i want to do but i just
don't know how to deal with that pawn on
e3
uh i mean after rook e3 here we just
get the exchange back everything from
black's perspective knight c4 at the end
and the king is safe and sound in the
corner the knight hits the queen attacks
the bishop and covers the check on e5
all at once so uh this would be
too good for black and bishop a3 the
choice maybe this bishop wants to go to
c5 it does cover all the way through to
f8
i still think knight c4 should be played
and knight c4 looks like the natural
move and well now uh i guess knight
seafood fabiano would put his bishop on
c5
and that's exactly i think what has just
happened knight c4 bishop c5 is on the
board and now where do we want to put
uh the queen c7 looks like the natural
square because the the white bishops are
covering a lot of the squares along that
uh seven strength so c7 looks like the
natural square
that's right because you don't want to
go the b file and invite a rook here
with a tempo and so queen g7 would be
the only other move but queen g7 it
feels a little bit too defensive whereas
the queen on c7 at least looks all
across the board towards the enemy king
while still doing what the queen on g7
does the d4 pawn is not going to be
targeted the bishop 1c5 does a nice job
of protecting it so i'm with you fiona
queen c7 looks like a great choice
and anish was anish's hand was hovering
over the queen i believe it's going to
be queen
c7
but some hesitations nerves are starting
to creep in as the clock drops under two
minutes still five moves to go uh four
anish four moves to go for fabiano but
anish i think we see it on his face he
knows he is in control now and if he can
keep his cool his main goal is to make
it to morph and move 40 while
maintaining his advantage and then he
will get get an extra 50 minutes um but
he needs to keep his cool for the next
five moves and he's dipping close to a
minute he is down on time but he's ahead
in position and he's bringing that queen
he's not sure
and that's what happens when you're
nervous queen g7 closer to the king i
thought he might do that and it's still
a very good position for black
but he goes towards the king to make
sure it's safe and sound yeah i guess
well he's uh from g7 one of those graves
he's covering that he wasn't before his
f6 so maybe at some point uh the bishop
from g5 could come back uh drop back to
f6 and try and put pressure again on
that pawn uh on the four and knife
inches as you say it makes sense to
in that spot where you want to reach the
time control safely to keep the most
powerful piece close to your king
i don't even know what white does here i
mean it says
like black has a huge advantage and i'm
trying to find an individual move and
i'm not finding rook f1 it does come to
mind but there's knight d2 with a fork
rook b1 open file knight d2 with a fork
so
you can't go to f1 or b1
you don't really want to move your queen
off the f file
so
what move to make here i do not know
i really
really don't know what a
a tough position for fabiano
and
i mean it's even it's tough looking at
him on the camera seeing fabiano uh
clearly nervous the position is bad but
you have to make a move you have to find
a move that that keeps some chances that
is going to give you some
something
you would love to make a move like h4
work but can we prepare that somehow
try but this rook is coming to e8 and
the knight is already on c4 so
you know even if you get h4 in it
doesn't feel like
you're doing enough because the pawn e3
is protected this is
this is as bad as it gets
and fabiano uh he is dropping down to to
just 30 seconds on the clock he has just
made a move and it's queen to g4
okay h4 your idea it's what he's going
for
he needs something to do
and that's black now
do you want to activate the rook
i like that i would bring my rook over
not to f8 don't forget the bishop does
cover the square but i would like to
bring my rook somewhere like rookie 8
looks really nice if the bishop ever
moves the rook can even
jump into the e4 square and don't count
on bishop g8 at some point
like the bishop's not looking good on
h7 but if the rook comes to eat and play
bishop g we get behind our past pawn by
the way i mean we highlighted d2 as a
square where there's some potential for
some potential action but i'm also
seeing f2
which is only three jumps away for the
night so we could see some potential
rewriting of the knight but uh anish
instead starts with bishop to f6
he's playing very defensively but he's
going to turn that defense into offense
if he gets his g5 and you called for the
bishop e4 type of ideas that's what's
about to happen but the c2 pawn is also
hanging i don't think that either player
really cares about that they do care
about their clock and fabian down to 35
seconds and he's staying in the game
right now he needs to find a move i
would just play probably rook to b1 and
hope to get played down the b file and
that's exactly what fabiano does rook
ab1 is on the board and now i'm curious
is follow up idea g5 now that the bishop
has been removed
he is reaching out both players really
now on the last
uh the last seconds under a minute both
of them
with still three moves to go for anish
two moves for
do fabiano think it's gonna be g5
g5 it's a good looking move but then
white will play bishop f5 so you see
that bishop trade happens the black king
loses one of its defenders and we've
seen anish play it safely this far it
looks like he went
a5
g5
d5 is on the board as you say um
fabiano very likely will meet it with
bishop f5 because i don't think you can
allow
the black bishop to land on e4
and uh
fabiano
he is fighting to stay alive here we saw
that the bar didn't love the move bishop
f6 it wasn't a bad move by any means
maybe there was better but with the
players both under a minute um
very tough situation 20 seconds
remaining now for fabiano two moves to
go under 20 seconds
right and the thing about bishop f5 the
bad thing about it at least is it allows
black just take it and then you're
getting close to the time control and
black is better pretty much no matter
what so if they reach that critical move
40 then anish can start sitting and
thinking the real question is has he
given up too much of his advantage and
will that allow fabiano to survive
great question robert it's so tough to
say
two moves to go for a niche and taking
on f5 as you said will bring him closer
it also makes sense to swap
those bishops i don't think well you
could maybe let
white trade but you don't want to drop
back to to g8
30 seconds for anish and he has to make
a decision will he trade on on f5 and if
not uh is it time to activate the rook
from a8 do we have to be concerned about
the right rook on b1 coming in so many
things to consider here
and you know the d4 pawn he goes rook to
e8 it looks like the d4 pawn could be
captured had the bishops and swapped on
f5 and the queen gone here but that was
not a good decision because the queen
needs to stay on the seventh rank
otherwise a rook lands on b7 and we just
see the evaluation bar go nearly level
at this point fiona i'm not sure what
the move is i don't think bishop takes
h7 looks that great for white the queen
can take and head into e4 so there's a
move here for fabi
what what
what just happened oh my i think we just
witnessed
an absolute
rarity at this level
did you see that
i think fabiano actually just forgot
about that knight
oh my goodness he just
forgot the knight could hop backwards
like that i mean he just wasn't looking
at the knight he's looking tonight you
know maybe defending e3 hopping into d2
earlier and he puts his rook on b6 and
it's just a blunder and these things
happen when you're so nervous you've
been making all sorts of moves with you
know a minute on your clock and after
rook b6 knight takes b6 the game is just
over oh my goodness i i mean
this is really
really tragic and you got a feel for
fabiano he did
such a great job uh holding on to this
difficult position throughout the time
scramble and then at the last hurdle
move 40
we were wondering the bar had just gone
back to more or less even
and then fabiano playing this move uh
rook b6 which was just a complete over a
blind spot
and you know the evaluation bar is
helpful for people at home and to know
what's going on in the game the players
have no idea i mean they both probably
just assumed that black was much better
because as i looked at that position
like how in the world can this be almost
level and if we go back a turn before
rook b6 was made i mean that would be a
good move if the knight weren't on c4
but of course it is i'm trying to figure
out here like what to do
because it still looks so good for black
you have this past pawn
need the knight here on c4 protecting it
the rook
behind the passport if you take on h7
you're trading pieces in a way that
favors black queen h7 c2 is hanging
queen e4 can trade the queens if you uh
feel the need to do that so it's just a
bad position on the surface but there
was i guess one move to make here that
would have allowed white to
stay in the game
well i mean i am i am lost for words
robert i think it's so rare and i don't
know what anish is doing because i
thought it was his move sometimes the
player they just take a breather on
mufordi um
fabiano i mean we saw him
looking
in shock
we saw anish give a look after he took
the rook on b6
and
we see anish interestingly not sitting
down at the board i think there's also
so much
adrenaline and so many emotions when
when you've been in a spot
both players where the time was so low
and then the whole time scramble
ends which is a completely unexpected
blunder
yes and i do think
that it was just those those nerves
getting to both the players and
inaccuracies happen especially when you
don't have much time remaining and you
know this position here instead of rook
to b6 sure move like rookie two i'm
still trying to figure out what the move
that should it just doesn't look equal
to me even if rookie two
yeah no that's not the right move but
that looks like you know a waiting move
um
like why in the world this position is
anywhere remotely close to level is
shocking but
um you know both players definitely
thought black at this point was well
ahead
and well if we bring back the the
current position
uh on the on the board so now with
uh with anish having picked up that rook
suddenly he um
he is no longer material down instead he
is simply two pawns up
uh he still keeps his big trumped upon
on uh e3
so
this position here uh is just winning
for for black
for sure you can take on f5 now and then
take on d4 take another pawn in the
center your king
is safe enough because white doesn't
have enough pieces to go and checkmate
you if you trade on d4 the queen is
coming to e4 with check to try to trade
the queen so anish you know he's just
calming himself before making moves and
he's certainly going to win this game
and wow i mean what a moment this was
here
fiona rook to b6 a blunder in a tough
spot and
i did glance over at the chat queen h5
apparently was a move that keeps white
hanging in there but it just doesn't
really feel that clear nonetheless even
if that move is good to begin with
coming up with the follow-ups to
hold this game would have been difficult
but of course the game would have
continued without black just being
instantly winning yeah what a move queen
h5
not an easy move to see by any means but
you've got to feel uh for fabi on the
other hand geary fans
will be happy with anish about to get
his first win of course that's not how
how the players want to win but they
they will take it a point is a point
especially with the black pieces anish
has captured on f5 and i expect actually
fabiano to
to probably just resign here because
after queen takes bishop takes
b4 the king is safe and um yeah there's
just nothing there
um so fabiano he did recapture on f5
and
anish will probably simply just take the
pawn
and fabian didn't play this game in his
trademark style from the very early
stages with the fiance bishops it wasn't
the principal chess of putting your
pawns in the center and uh you know
playing in that manner so yeah i could
tell as soon as the opening was played
that fabiano he's frustrated with his
results because his play overall has
been quite good and he gets yes panko
yesterday he was the one with the
advantage the entire game before it went
away from him so uh you know he will go
to a minus one score of two and a half
at a six but based on the play here
before this game i think that's what led
him to this moment credit to anish giri
who didn't have much time and put up
some first a great play on the queen
side and then great defense on the king
side yeah i mean what a game this has
been so much back and forth uh let's
quickly check in with sergey karjakin
and jordan uh van forest and then
we'll go on a quick break to
also recover
from all the emotions i mean what a what
a day and what a what a game what a time
scramble we've just witnessed
this is not pleasant to look at black
can hardly move and the way that white
is going to win is your upper pawn and
you want to punch through a5 but i'm
just looking at this is this white king
is at some point going to walk in and
just end the game and
there's just
black just doesn't have moves so uh if
we trade knights because both the knight
on e7 the pawn g7 are under attack then
we can put our knight on e4
and then we can just start bringing our
king up the board black needs to stay in
line with move a5 otherwise white gets a
clear pass pawn so now fiona this is uh
this is as bad as it gets from the
perspective of jordan von forrest yeah
and it looks like it's going to be quite
a decisive game so far only one decisive
result magnus carlton as victory over
richard report but any giri and sergey
karyakin
are inching closer and closer to making
that
a tree
decisive games day
and
robert i think we're going to take a
quick break
and then we'll be back very shortly with
the last two games going here
in round six
[Music]
so
my first memory would be being here with
my grandfather and my little brother
playing here for the very first time i
was playing in the amateur sections and
really desperately trying to get a look
at
the two players playing
so my best memory would have to be
definitely
while winning here last year without
question
a couple of years ago we started getting
neural network chess engines
into the into the
jazz world and they really changed the
game
the way we see the game
very differently and it has improved our
understanding of the game immensely so
it's a very interesting development and
the way they play chess is really
magnificent so it's it's very nice
have a chessboard at home so i like to
bring a chessboard to my tournaments but
um
90 of the work i think does take place
on my laptop and using technology
i always think that like the engines we
currently have they're like the
strongest
there can ever be but they keep on
getting stronger so who knows
what's going to come in the future
i've basically played in all of the
groups and indeed that
just coming here as a kid and now
playing on the highest stage is of
course
very special to me
[Music]
just heard from jordan van furies the
defending champion but he is in big
trouble today against sergey
karjakin we see the results
so far we've had four draws
and one big win for magnus carlsen who
has joined
the leaders
um robert
out of the four draws which was the one
which piqued your interest the most
well the game between shanklin and
pragananda that was over pretty quickly
because it was great preparation by
black ragnan showed some excellent home
prep and was able to draw easily the
game between vidit and duda that was
also fantastic home prep by duda and he
was able to make the draw mama jarvan
niels
they played like 15 moves and then the
draw was offered and agreed to so
last but not least it had to be duboff
against jessepanko where duvet had
pressure and andre played really well to
stave him off and hold the half point
absolutely
kudos to sergey yasipanko but it looks
like one russian player today will get a
full point and that is sergey karyakin
he is still looking for his first win of
the this year's tournament but he will
uh very likely just get it against
jordan today we've just brought up the
position and this a5 push that you have
been talking about for so long that has
just happened
yeah he went a5
and importantly uh jordan took on a5 but
let's say
king b7 was played a6 check you try to
say i'm gonna have a connected pass pawn
and maybe you will in fact win this game
because black is tied down the
nerve-wracking part about this is that
if you don't open up the other side of
the board you can't make progress over
here there's no way a knight gets to c6
for white to check the king because a5
is covered d4 is covered and i don't
know where else your knight thinks it's
going but it's not going d8 and getting
to c6 but that's why you have the whole
other flank to work with and you'd have
to switch your attention over this way
black would be playing without a king
and that means that white has an extra
piece to
utilize in the break on the king side
yes so this
wouldn't have helped jordan
instead he captured
on a5 and after rook takes uh brought
the knight back to c8
trying to control uh the a7 square
but uh sergey karjakin rook a6 and where
is that
rook
um
what's the idea behind rook a6 robert
so rook c6 check is something to
consider if the knight leaves
c8 there could be a timely rook a7 check
and what
sergey is going to do is put his knight
on a5 i believe defend the c4 pawn so
that his other knight can start doing
work on the king side he could bring the
knight back to d2 if he doesn't want to
get his rook sort of trapped over here
but there's nothing to attack the rook
with if you move the c8 knight there's
still rook a7 if you move the b6 knight
there's rook c6 at the very least so the
rook's not getting trapped although how
to
break through from here that's the
question that remains to be seen because
you need to
somehow break down the other flank
otherwise there's no progress to be had
on the queen side right now and i think
karjakin is going to show us just how
because he has gone
to a5 so now his own rook uh
a bit trapped in the enemy lines but
also
uh tying down uh jordan's pieces
and well white is going to be looking
at to somehow mobilize the the pawns uh
on the the king side i guess or try and
activate uh his king
yeah because
a7 a8 are under black's control so if
you just
to make random moves is white you're not
going to be able to
break through so you can bring this
knight to f5 that looks pretty good
because after g6 there's a knight g7
then you get your knight to e6 with
check and that's a very big problem for
uh black here is a fork but even if the
rook were to move away somewhere after a
96 check the king has to go and then
once the king goes i mean this looks
like there's a mating net in the works i
haven't quite figured out how to deliver
a checkmate but it should be theirs
shortly it's such a weird position with
all of white's pieces in the enemy lines
both knights and the rook they are all
in blacks side of the board
um we see the the evaluation by a scar
at the evaluation by a sky high but
still yeah where was the knockout it
feels like it can't be too far out um
what if we bring another knight to c6
i'm still not sure what my follow-up is
after that maybe can i bring a knight to
a7 and try and break uh this wall of the
two black knights
that looks
like a great idea and it you give up
upon c4 that's your extra pawn but
that's not important because now what
was that knight doing covering a8 rook
a8 rook b8 rook b7 you worked your rook
to the seventh rank and this king it's
just going to get
checkmated yeah so uh
well it's looking very good for sergey
of course he also has plenty of time on
the clock and he has actually just made
a move and the knight has
jumped into f5 indeed and
while we just saw g6 didn't look
too tempting but if not g6 then how do
you deal with the pawn being attacked on
g7 rook g8 is really not a move you want
to make but maybe
maybe you just have to defend passively
you do because any pawn move you make in
addition to knight g7 being an idea it
makes the f6 uh pawn in some danger so
he did go rook to f7 and you see the
evaluation part go up even more i
imagine you can bring your king up king
f3 king g4 you can play the move pawn h4
and
that's just trading off one pair of
pawns but then your king is going to
just walk up into the action so what you
do is you take away the g6 push and so
your king can just
just very straightforward whether it's
f5 or h5 the king is getting in
and i mean sergey
he's been around the block for a fair
few years
he
in general is a very accurate very
technical player and i think
he's going to show us without any
hesitation here what the best path
for for why it is
meanwhile let's leave these guys and
quickly check in with
fabiano and anish that's the other game
that's still ongoing if you're just
tuning in now
this could took
quite a dramatic turn after
a very eventful back and forth uh middle
game uh fabiano unfortunately just had a
blind spot on move 40 the last move
before the time control and gave up the
rook on b6 for a second probably just
just forgetting about that knight on c4
um anish took and then he just took
everything he took on f5 he took on d4
fabiano took on a5
and but it's what it's
two extra pawns for black and the
question is just how do you mobilize
them in the best way
can anish maybe activate the rook
and does he he moved upon he has
so many good moves to choose from
yeah i'm trying to think which of those
many good options should he choose from
he tried to trade queens with queen e5
he could push the pawn to e2
the problem sometimes pushing your pawn
there is that it's not as well defended
so if
white can attack the e2 square with the
queen and then
you know avoid black from protecting it
then maybe that pawn is one but of
course this queen can jump in to e5 or
e7 things like that so
all these moves look quite good one
thing though to consider is if you play
e2 now you actually struggle to trade
queens as black because this king
perhaps in some universe is close enough
it's it won't be because this rook can
come to e3 and it's just not going to
happen so even if you pushed upon e2 and
white is able to put pressure on it you
still can't win it so there's no
there's no way that i see
that a niche can go wrong here blunders
happen especially in time trouble but
anish has so much time remaining and
yeah i just can't see him not winning
this game we talked about the queen
trade i was wondering is bishop c3 also
an option maybe try and trade the
bishops
undoubtedly and after bishop c3
you
hit the bishop you hit the rook once the
trade happens it's very important that
this rook is under attack
because if this rook were not under
attack from queen g6 would be a big
problem hitting the rook on 8 and this
h6 pod but this rook is hanging and
hanging with check so i'm trying to like
if i give white a free move just bear
with me for a second and get this
position right then the move queen g6
would be pretty annoying because of the
rook hanging and this pawn hanging as
well so
it happens to be
still in white's favor in this
particular position but there could be
another where
you lose sight of your king safety as
black and then spoil the victory but
here pretty much everything is winning
as is the point and anish's hand was
hovering over uh the bishop
on d4 to me it looked like he was gonna
go bishop c3
but well anish he's gotten an extra 15
minutes on the clock he's going to make
double sure um that
the gift he received well i was gonna
say he received a gift from fabiano
which is is true in some way and there
would have been a lot more work would
have had to go into the the game without
the rook
b6 mistake but anish all credit to him
he played i think a really nice game uh
it was so complex for but it's so it's
so hard to even explain and tell the
story of this game i think
anish got a nice position out of the
opening and then the initiative just
went back and forth
but all in all i think anish played a
really nice game
yeah the way i would describe it is that
for the first let's say
20 plus moves anish was out playing
fabiano that was clear and then
he he
took a bit too long he became a bit
passive and he was trying to stop
fabinho playing f4 and f5 and he put his
pieces in that direction and yet fabiano
still played f5 and then had the
advantage so that was some inaccuracy
from anish then after f5 it was very
complicated and the position opened up
it became tactical and yet anish was
ready for it and in the ensuing time
trouble it was anybody's game but it
seemed like a niche had the upper hand
there uh through and through and he i
think deserves the point that he's about
to get
yeah and uh that victory uh once he gets
it is gonna take
anish back to 50
it will be his first uh win of the
tournament we remember his round two
loss against magnus carlsen and uh on 50
percent he won't be too far of the lead
for fabiano it will be a tough loss he
had a few chances but all his games so
far ended in draws um so fabiano will
have to to come back
into the tournament and he is still
chasing his first one
and our daily shout out for a certain
player who's not in the master session
it's arjun aragaisi who has moved to
five and a half out of six he wins his
game against his compatriot
surya ganguly and so for
arjuna it doesn't look like he can be
stopped he's just on a path straight for
the top and he has only given up one
draw in six rounds he is not in the
masters yet robert because let's remind
our viewers the winner of the challenger
challengers tournament gets an invite to
next year's masters group
and well at the moment i mean what even
is his lead uh
after six rounds
it looks like the closest pursuant
at the moment is uh juma jumabayev who's
already a point and a half uh behind so
yeah just what a
an incredible start to to the tournament
for
for arjun and the meanwhile anish has
indeed played bishop c3
he has and
well for fabiano he he trades he had no
choice and after the queen recaptures on
c3
the rook is hanging here
there is one trick so just a little
trick here
if white makes the move king g2 oh no my
rook eric rosen says
queen takes e1 would be a terrible
choice because queen f6 check makes a
draw if your king goes to g8 queen g6 in
whichever way your king goes my queen
goes in the same direction and i make a
draw if your king had gone to h7 i go
queen f7 check after king h8 yeah i can
take your rook and likely still make a
draw but i know that this was the
position we started with so i'm just
going to make this repetition here and
there's nothing that can be done from
black's point of view so
don't just take free pieces simply
because they're free
yeah and i mean eric rosen what an
influence on the game he has had uh i
will never forget actually robert one of
my favorite moments of this past year
was you commentating on ludwig's game in
the puck gems with the infamous uh
letter
free move stalemate
yeah i don't want to talk about that um
you know that wasn't his finest moment
but it did make excellent content and so
yes those uh pre-moving can go wrong
taking rooks that are hanging sometimes
can go wrong
but anish is not going to make any
mistakes here this deep into the game he
is really just completely winning and i
think even the bar
doesn't do it justice the fact is even a
sliver
of white on that bar is wrong
yeah and um
i think it's just a tough spot for
for fabiano uh
where i think
part of you sometimes if i put myself
in in fabiano's shoes of course on a
different stage not at the tata still
masses but i've been there as well when
uh
you know these cruel blunders and
sometimes i think
you're just so
in shock that it takes a while to
[Music]
recover and sometimes
i'm not saying fabiano should resign but
sometimes it helps to just stay at the
board for a little while to to process
what even happened
for fabiano part of it i think fiona is
that his rating has been in free fall he
was you know in 2018 when he played
magnus carlson he was three rating
points behind magnus if if i had won a
single game within the match he would
have been the highest rated player in
the world and
over the last you know year two years
it's five machines rating go under 2800
when he loses this game i think he's
going to be 27.80 or something like that
and it's weird to even think in those
terms the good news the bright side for
fabiano is he's already made the
candidates so that's the biggest term of
the year when he won the canons in 2018
he scored something like minus 27 rating
points in tata steel he was a 5 out of
13 a huge minus score he played some of
his worst chess relative to his strength
and yet he went on to win the candidates
and many other events so he needs to fix
something there are things that are
wrong he has a new
main trainer now he's no longer working
with russian kazum jhana that could be
affecting his play he did well in the
grand swiss in riga back in the fall of
2021 but right now
this tournament is not his most
tournaments that he's playing in doesn't
feel like
he's any classical chess that is he's
not at the forum that we saw
from him in the past
yeah and well of course he would
definitely oh and robert king g2
played by fabiano
well um it's a good attempt but instead
of taking you know how i like to stop
one square short of the expected move
queen d2 check would be the way to go
because if the king goes to h3 you're
all the way up in the open i feel like i
should be able to go check me your king
somehow but i have to watch out because
if i do allow queen to f6 that wouldn't
be
a good thing at all but i could imagine
like g4 check trying to draw the queen
back in which case you have no checks
at least not a check an endless series
of checks you get one on
d4 but after
king h7 queen d3 check the rook comes to
e4 and
that's it
yeah so uh queen d2 check and after
uh
the check what if white goes back to to
f1
i was envisioning
i don't have i thought e2 check would
just end the discussion and then after
king g2 i realized i still can't take
the rook i don't have any checks so then
i want to figure out what to do about my
king i mean still it's clear that black
is doing well but these are the moments
fiona where
when you're winning you didn't start
feeling i'm letting it slip and you can
get in your own head and that's why
anish has been spending so much time is
he wants to perfect this now so that
fabi has no hope
going forward
indeed and well robert i suggest we
listen to what uh magnus carlsen had to
say after his win over richard report
and then we'll come back to these last
two remaining games
magnus um you just beat richard report
with the white pieces um as jose
cerebral would say welcome to the club
of the pawn grabbers
yeah
sorry it was a very nice pond to have as
well um of course
since uh with the opposite colored
bishops um
uh such um
yeah
search upon on the flank is usually
pretty uh pretty hard to stop um and i
felt after he went for for c5 i thought
that was reasonable but maybe taking on
f3 was a bit
uh was a bit dodgy like he gets the pawn
back but
um
but uh i think the position at least in
practice will be very difficult to play
uh maybe should he should have done
something else there although everywhere
of course i'm
i'm fighting for for an advantage if
anyone um
yeah then um
uh
yeah i don't know what happened later he
clearly should have tried to keep the d4
pawn to gain any counter play uh i think
after or grabbed d4 it's just um it's
just very very bad for him so i don't
know what he missed there yeah um
the past the previous two games were
quite wild uh was it nice to change the
character of the game a little bit yeah
but it was also well
if not exactly wild then it was a bit
unusual then in that we both took a very
long time to think at an early stage um
because this position was practically
it was practically new at that point uh
but um yeah like we should be three yeah
bishop b3 of course and then bishop d6
was a bit of a super surprising response
and
feels like it on
on almost we we have
both have a lot of alternatives so there
was a lot of to consider and
sort of
ended up making the most obvious moves
which usually happens even after
a long think
but yeah um
last couple of games of course um they
were very complicated and
i was really um upset with myself after
after yesterday after
uh i think i missed some
[Music]
some uh some chances there after the
time control uh of course a lot of
things happened before that but um that
was that was really really sloppy um and
um were you were you by the way in
serious danger in the opening against
brandelus yeah i guess i was in
it wasn't a lot of danger i just mixed
up the preparation i played d5 one move
too early um but i think we're
since i was blissfully unaware during
the game i wasn't so worried uh even
though i didn't exactly see how it was
going to work for
for for me uh and i think even if he had
played correctly there
even though he's he's a lot better i
still have practical chances and
it just took really one move by
four that was very logical but still
a bit of a mistake and then i was
already doing very well practically
speaking and even
even
had a decent position in general so
but yeah i really really needed the win
today um after
throwing away some some opportunities
the last last round and yeah now
everything is looking a lot better
yesterday the new season of the
meltwater champions tour was announced
how excited are you for the new season
and
um
are you
involved with
decision making uh while being here in
vikranze um i'm not uh making the
decisions but i'm i guess i'm an advisor
here
but i'm i'm really uh
uh i'm really excited for the new season
to begin um and
yeah just let's bring it on but
a lot of chess to be played here still
before that good thank you thank you
magnus clearly uh very happy and
relieved to get the full point here
after a game that he called as sloppy uh
yesterday against nils gandalius
yeah there was a game where he has some
regrets clearly
but today he has none because he won a
good game he now moves to a tie for the
lead and anish just brought his king out
of the corner to g7 he's clearly
threatening the move rook to f8 pinning
and winning the queen and he allows a
check on d7 fiona but he's just saying
that you get a check maybe two but your
king is still the one that's going to
get checkmated yeah so let's have a look
the problem is that after the check on
d7 maybe the king can go out white will
not be in time to take the rook because
there is a mate threatened on f2
and if the king is on f6 well where are
the checks there's one check
on c6 one on d6 but both of them run
into rook e6 and
the checks don't run on out just yet
there's another check on f8
but after king g6
queen g8
king
where's that king gonna run
maybe it's a choice
yeah it has a choice here because the
king just keeps running
and vidit and you scary good friends
that king on f5 it's in a good spot
they're just a couple more checks and
once you block them or bring your king
up to a square like g4 for instance the
checks are just clearly running out and
this is what is happening right now on
the board after the check on d7 anish
indeed did go up to f6 and queen d6 will
probably see
rookie 6 be played although
moving the king also seems fine
and there's these two games remaining
and this one
is very bad for white down two pawns and
with your king uh just about to be mated
on f1 and the other game is no more
pleasant to look at because fiona
there's a knight on
e6 there and a knight on c6 so we were
you know not messing around when we
showed a position like this earlier in
the analysis oh my god this is really
really painful to look at let's bring up
let's bring up that board and see
how did jordan find himself in this
pickle i mean the position was
already lost let's uh we're not gonna
try and talk the talk here but as sergey
karjakin i did say he was going to show
us how it's done and he has just been
dancing
those knights around into a perfect
position
yeah then it went via f8 to e6 and the
king comes to d7 and your idea on knight
a7 it forces at least one knight off the
board because after knight takes a7 we
can just take either knight and fly
tries to escape then the b6 knight is
hanging that's why it was so important
to check the black king away from the
knight because if the king were on c7
still the knight could then release the
e7 but here the knight can't move
without losing
his partner on b6 and yeah this is just
this is over once one night goes the
b-pawn is free or the seventh rank is
whites for the taking
and i think we've come back here just in
time jordan just
gave the kind of sigh
uh that
lets us know the end
is near let's show one more time what
happens if jordan takes the pawn on c4
okay
go ahead
well the rook oh we can we can take
there as well i was wondering if you
wanted to bring the rook to c7
and it's a kind of position where
there's so many
so many moves from that we can have
different um
we can each pick our own
but you know it's just so unpleasant
it's actually even material in this
position believe it or not but the king
has no moves brook a check is going to
win this rook if you're not careful
knight takes g7 or rook take g7 can be
played i can just help escort my b-pawn
up the board so yeah your rook c6 it uh
showcases why we've been working so hard
to get rid of the knight and
will we see it rook c6
and yeah um carrier can two move now it
is the move i expect and he has played
it instantly he foresaw all of this uh
from a distance
and
yeah that the end is near here for for
you then
the reason i like this more your
variation that kayak can just play it is
because how do you take it on c8 while
it still is very clearly just dominating
for white the you brought your
opponent's rook towards the queen side
where you have a pass pawn and behind
his pass pawn so there's no reason to
allow that rook into the game in this
manner it's still just crushing the only
move is king here you take the pawn you
can bring your knight back if you want i
mean you have all the time in the world
to do things you're king well not there
but we'll probably just walk up the
board and help deliver the checkmate but
i really like your move way way way more
because after rook c7 check it's just
the the black rook is caught doing
nothing so you're not helping your
opponent
at all
and we see jordan there and just well
reaching out his hand in resignation and
that game is
over and uh
it's we haven't seen so many of these
really positional master classes but
sergey sort of from the opening we
thought that there was some some counter
play for jordan we liked the knights
looking like they were coming into f4
but kyrie can just shut down all of
black's play
close the center and then slowly slowly
outplay jordan
yes and you see the players they're
talking about the game jordan had this
look on his face where he was
registering some variation that he just
didn't see during the game and karjakin
he's called the minister of defense
which is true he is so good at defending
tough positions being resourceful but as
he just showed you know if he can get
the type position where he can
squeeze he makes it look easy jordan had
no chance even though initially with his
knights coming to g6 and h5 he might
have a little something once g3 was
played and then especially when the
queens came off fiona it was all sergey
karyakin
indeed an impressive
impressive game by him and well let's
bring back fabiano's game against anish
where anish that king is just going
forward queen d7 is the last move
uh on the board and now anish blocks
with rookie six
and um
there are a few more checks but it looks
like they are going to run out soon
and he just glanced up at fabiano a
couple of times he's like looking at him
what does he see the answer is nothing
just a couple more checks as you said
and the evaluation bar without
suggesting checkmate by force it's
pretty much as low as it gets
yeah and uh and he's just getting ready
after queen h7 check that king
is it going further forward yes it is
the king is
on uh on g4 and
well that's it there are no more checks
so now fabiano if he wants to play on he
will have to defend
at the mate
on f
but yeah there's just too many pieces
around the the white king and this one
is over
right because queen f7 is the only way
to deal with the checkmate there and
then you you are threatening to take
this rook so you you say oh i can leave
my rook here because if they take his
checkmate you have to remember your king
is in check so as long as anish doesn't
blunder that which he won't
he can bring his rook up to e4 to help
out deliver uh
the maids just
yeah that's
nothing poppy i can do
now we see
um i think he will try queen f7 so queen
f7
has been played and
i like your move
look to e4
i guess anisha is a little bit spoiled
as long as he is spoiled for choice as
long as he doesn't blunder the work with
jack maybe rookie five
also
good enough
i mean pretty much any any rook move
that isn't for f6 even rook e7 i don't
know what that achieves other than
looking cute
um
but yeah
just the only thing is do not blunder
network with jack
and you're right though any rook move
seriously e7 ea e5 e4
not rook f6 and not leaving the rook
here those are the two bad moves because
when the queen takes an f6 it still
covers the checkmate but the point that
we're making is that if the rook is
captured anywhere else the queen has
left its guard of the f2 square so just
do not leave it here with the king on g4
and
anish
he is getting ready
i think
very likely it would be your move rookie
four
well he's got the hand on the head and
oh
he can move his king to h4 but
we've i've to close up ready
where is he going to go and i think
we've got uh sergey karyakin uh just
starting his interview
so let's go over there no no we're not
okay um so
we're still waiting on anish to decide
where
where to go and there it is rook e4 is
on the board
all right well
i don't know and a handshake
exactly i said i don't even know what to
do fabiano resigns
he did blunder or rook on b6 that was a
clear blunder but still he was in a
tough spot and anish made one
maybe a couple mistakes to allow fabian
the play that he got and without
the perfect play from fabiano he was not
able to sustain the advantage he was
able to obtain yeah and uh well this was
a big game because between two of the
top-rated players here four niche fans
it's a great day at the office the local
dutch hero he gets a huge win with the
black pieces over fabiano so he is back
in the tournament for fabiano hopefully
he can bounce back
as soon as tomorrow
and he's just been in a bit of a slump
and chess players go through those uh
some of the most famous
players and best players in history like
vasily ivan
he went from like nearly 2 800 down to
2720 back to 2780 so some players go in
waves and rapport actually as one of
those players he was 27.50 down to even
the 2600s and of course now he's one of
the absolute best players in the world
once more
and there we see the the look into the
playing hall with our main arbiter
arnold he's
getting ready to
maybe get the score sheets or put the
boards back but he understands the
players are not ready to call it a day
just yet and i mean it was such an
interesting complex game so of course
plenty uh to discuss
uh for the two players
it's actually kind of funny because i
was about to say they're the only people
remaining in the playing hall just let
them analyze and then i remember the
challenger section is right over there
so talking is distracting and as we see
here on the screen there are several
games still going in the challenger
section and that's likely why the
arbiter is going to try to say all right
i respect you both amazing chess but
please talk about it elsewhere
yeah and i think the players are getting
ready we see anish they're just
handing the score sheet
to the
and there is there is actually an
analyzer sport in the back room usually
there's plenty more but in these
pandemic times but i think that's gonna
be it i think fabiano um
as lovely as he is as nice i think after
a move like uh rook b6 even if you're
interested in what happened beforehand i
think part of you just wants to to get
back to the room
well i think part of him just wants to
leave vikings a he's not having a good
tournament and when that happens and
there's still
seven rounds remaining you do have time
to start stringing together some
victories sure but you're also like this
tournament is bad and i really hope it
doesn't get worse yeah and there we see
the results today once again uh plenty
of decisive uh decisive action with
magnus carlsen winning his game against
richard rapport does joining
the three-way tie at the top
um
or actually not joining
because he
dethroned richard sorry robert my brain
is working slowly but then we saw anish
geary win his game against fabiano
carrana sergey uh karjakin the author of
a nice mass uh position on masterpiece
against jordan van pers and the other
games ending in draws
that's right so actually max does join
excuse me a three-way tie for first
because he joins vidit and mama jarv but
uh report now has to settle for being a
half point behind the leaders he is
joined by andre yes panko and then anish
giri they're in sixth place so he jumps
from two out of five to three out of six
and he's joined from sixth through
eighth so really all these players
all the way up to eighth place i would
say still in very good shape in this
tournament especially as you know it's
around robin you have to play everyone
in this tournament but vidiq gujarati
still having a great event mama jarv was
in a risky spot today but he was able to
offer the draw and have it accepted and
then magnus carlson you do not if you're
the rest of the field want to see him
charging ahead with more victories
indeed so
uh there's plenty here to play for
tomorrow round seven robert uh you won't
be here dania will
be here instead but once again we've got
so many exciting clashes uh to look
forward to at the top there the the
bottom seat playing the top seed
pragnanda against magnus carlsen what
are your expectations for that
i'm excited for the youngster because
they have not played in classical chess
before and it's an amazing opportunity
but don't get me wrong probably none is
not just going to say i'm just happy to
play he gets the white pieces there's no
reason why he should go into that game
fearing magnus carlsen you respect the
world champion but you do not fear him
and i don't think pragmata has shown any
fear so i'm really looking forward to
that match up the teenager from india he
could potentially take down magnus
carlson even though magnus has not lost
yet it is always possible when a strong
player takes on the world champion and
it will be their first classical
encounter so there will be that special
flavor to it the other two games that
i'm very excited about is the the other
two co-leaders mom and diary of playing
black against richard to report i have
no idea what to expect for that game i
think anything could happen and a jordan
van ferece
after his loss today against karjakin
i'll be very curious to see how he
bounces back with the white pieces
against david
and they're just some very interesting
middle of the pack pairings as well
nishkiri gets white he just won against
five on the karwana he gets to play
duboff duboff undoubtedly a bit
frustrated with how the games have gone
he lost the game early in the tournament
he could not win today's game so aneesh
giri i mean he can win another if he's
playing his best chess and dubova isn't
in his top form so watch out for niche
to start working his way back towards
the top
absolutely robert uh it's the end of the
day here but we are not done just yet we
are gonna go on a quick break and we are
when we are back uh well you'll get your
rapid recap of the day so don't go
anywhere we'll be back with that
[Music]
anish geary just beat fabiano carawana
with the black pieces how would you
describe this game
yeah i
don't know either i sort of i'm not a
very good chess player in general or
somehow the positions i'm getting are
too complicated for me and the engines
are too strong somehow i don't know like
if i look at my games after the game
they're so bad like today also it was
just such a disaster i thought it was an
interesting game while we were playing
it and okay of course i missed few
things but when i checked it afterwards
it was so bad i don't know what to think
about jess is a very rich game of course
you make mistakes or you're not like
it's so bad i mean like i was like my
the evaluations that i see i mean i
thought it was an unclear position where
i'm probably slightly better and i see
like it's like minus two point half i
don't know like on what square it can be
minus two point half is like an extra
piece almost
then uh get i make some mistakes
then it's like i thought okay probably
there is some crush for him well that
he's actually winning i'm not surprised
but then yeah later as well like no i
just didn't have the right evaluation
throughout towards the end of the time
control i was really happy that i am
alive because i felt i was losing at
some point
but it didn't really occur to me that
i'm already much
much much like i'm winning actually at
the time
but okay we're both uh in huge time
pressure and um made a lot of mistakes
actually uh on move 40 i saw the smooth
queen h5 that he could make
which was very strong but actually i
thought okay i'm probably still fine and
game goes on okay can you introduce that
moment like uh what what was the time
situation around 40. it was already once
minutes per uh we had like a minute
already for a while both of us um
i mean i was sort of happy that uh i got
my knights to c4 pawn only three is live
and i was really happy to be in the game
and i just thought the priority right
now is not to blunder anything before
the time control
which i sort of didn't but in the
meantime of course i made many mistakes
yeah but he played this he
took his rook from b1 put it on b6
like what what uh what what came to your
mind at that moment yeah he blundered
the rook i guess or it happens
he doesn't know how the horsey moves or
no no he does but
steven chuck once said knight moves
backwards are the hardest moves in chess
but not for you
no no
you know
that's the hardest but still you can
make them
but yeah i was pretty i mean i'm more
like okay i was lucky in the end of
course but i'm really
sort of somewhat confused at how
poor my games are in general um so
after this interview you just i guess
you just go back to your hotel room you
just check it with like a better engine
um how much time will you spend like
analyzing this game before prepping for
tomorrow not too much tomorrow is a very
exciting game uh here actually we play i
play three games uh against members of
uh world championship match preparation
uh even more she said he also was
involved and that's really challenging
because these guys are really well
prepared um you know i work very hard uh
but um there are a few months always
every two years where i'm
not exactly up there
in terms of preparation because these
guys they worked harder and um
more intensely with more people and
better hardware so
i'll be
really curious as to how my preparation
will match tomorrow against daniel and
looking forward to that so i will not
have too much time looking at my game
but
i don't know i have to somehow uh stop i
don't know maybe stop analyzing my games
or something because they're they're so
bad it's just not
not really um
inspiring confidence i think also i
haven't played the classical chess in a
while and i've sort of assumed that
maybe not rapid blitz should be bad but
classical chess is going to be better
but of course yeah if you look at the
other games as well the quality of play
is really low uh
all over the place so maybe chess is
just very hard
maybe you need like a friend or a coach
who just gives you like a thumbs up and
says like hey anish you're doing great
uh yeah i know people say that but just
like i look at the games myself and you
know i see all these mistakes it's
really hard to
to get confidence there but of course
i'm really happy today it's very
important to have a lucky break it would
have made a huge difference had i not
won today so i'm really excited to
continue the tournament i'm now maybe
back it depends on how the rest of the
games go and yeah tomorrow is going to
be definitely a fun game okay all the
best thank you thanks
always great to hear anish geary's
thoughts he's happy after a win but he's
still very critical of his play fiona so
uh you know what do you think about that
yeah i
uh it's interesting i didn't expect
anish to come out and the first thing
for him to say
uh to be
i played so bad i think maybe i'm not
sure how i feel about anish he does this
i think he's the only player who
consistently when he finishes his game
he is looking for the nearest laptop he
can find and he likes to get the
immediate feedback of the engine and i
think he was just shocked today um that
the engine was saying he was so winning
and
for me it's kind of um
[Music]
almost i was gonna say sad i don't know
sad is the right word but to see such a
great player like anish uh
to have the his judgment his immediate
judgment after the game you know it's
almost like the computers take away from
our joy
of winning a game you've just beaten
um fabiano carrana as black of course
there was this rook b6 moment but um
yeah don't let the the computers ruin
your joy like that
they certainly can because you know that
as well as you play you didn't play
perfectly but alas he rips the band-aid
off he wants to get the knowledge over
with did i play
how well did i play did i play you know
a great game did i play a subpar game he
just wants that out of the way but we
are now in for an exciting treat it is
your day six rapid recap from tata seal
and we have a special one for you we are
choosing a game from the challenger
section it is arjun aragaisi taking on
his countryman surya ganguly and arjun
is arigaisi after six round robert he's
on five and a half out of six he drew
his first run game against lucas van
ferece and he's just been on the tear
ever since
he can't stop won't stop and in this
game we saw in a talon game but instead
of a quiet line with pawn to d3 we saw a
d4 fiona so it's clear that arjun was in
for a battle
absolutely
a fighting opening choice arjun a young
up-and-coming
player and he is not afraid to enter
some more tactical territory usually we
see the quieter d3 played
exactly just to defend the pawn on e4
and then castle and develop your pieces
but instead we see d4 and after pawn
takes d4 e5 d5 is an important strike
because the point is while your knight
is under attack you are attacking the
bishop on c4 opening up your bishop on c
bishop b5 the knight jumps in and fiona
after pawn takes bishop v6 this is a
position that is well known to these
players yes absolutely this position has
seen been seen thousands of times before
so we're still deep in uh
uh theoretical territory argentina
continues to develop with knight c3
yes he does and ganguly one of the best
prepared players himself has worked with
former world champion vichyanan as part
of his team he castles and after bishop
e3 we see the move f6 so fiona we
understand the move it challenges white
center but it's also a bit risky yeah as
ben feingold says never play f6 and this
is one of the positions where we
understand why does ben say that we look
at the king on g8 and we see that
a queen could potentially appear on b3
in either case you are opening up some
lines some diagonals in front of your
king and in general you have to be very
careful when making uh pawn moves like
that
for sure and in this one the pawn
captured through a knight takes c3
hitting the queen so you can't get away
with moving this f pawn after pawn takes
the queen takes f6 white castles black
plays bishop g4 and fiona here black
decides to take on f3 and now white is
the bishop pair yeah and well we'll see
uh
indian legend vishyana and he famous he
said he loves playing with the night
pair but
the new generation is here and let's see
how uh argentina put the bishop pair to
use
well after rook d8 he said let me drop
that bishop back to
e2 it's done its duty it won the enemy
bishop and now after knight a5 he pushes
pawn to a4 which means that the knight
is kind of stuck because if that knight
were to move too soon the white pawn
would venture forward for example after
here bishop takes c4 pawn takes c4
it doesn't quite trap the bishop yet
because there's bishop c5 but you need
don't need to win a full piece it's okay
because the bishop is under attack let's
move our queen to b1 out of the pin on
the d file once the bishop moves you
lose b7 you'll probably lose a7 c7 as
well it's not going to be good news for
black so that's why that knight has to
stay put on the a file over here c6
makes sense to solidify the center but
fiona after bishop d3 i know you're
liking the look of white's position yeah
and suddenly the bishops are getting
activated the bishop from b3 from d3 is
looking down all the way at h7 and well
we see on the very next move uh it's
like arjun was reading my mind the black
bishop dropped back to c7 and in comes
the most powerful piece queen g4 and
suddenly
well there's already a few threats all
the white pieces are getting ready to
look down towards the black king
that's right bishop g5 also a threat
that's why the rook came from d8 to e8
and honestly black's position looks
quite sound you have the rooks connected
right close to each other there are open
files that blacks rooks and queen are on
so that looks good but the problem is is
the game opens up the bishops show their
dominance and white when rookie won
black played the bishop to d8 didn't
want white to put a bishop on g5 and
here fiona this is one of the strangest
blunders i've seen not because it it's a
horrible move it looks like a perfectly
reasonable move but as we see after
queen f3 the evaluation goes sky high
for white
yeah it's such a as an interesting
moment queen f3 to the human eye looks
like a natural move you want to try and
trade the queens the black queen
infiltrates
the white position
but it turns out this was already the
maybe the decisive mistake arjun
says i'm not interested in a queen swap
those bishops are looking working
beautifully and now let me
look down at that weakness on h7
and the queen being on f3 gives the
bishop a tempo because after g6 bishop
e2 step one that bishop has gone all
over the board c4 b5 back to e2
capturing on f3 back to e2 to d3 now all
the way back to e2 and after the queen
drops back to f5 guess what it's that
bishop's time to move again with bishop
g4 yeah and once again i mean
could all of this lead back to the the
moment when ganguly decided to play f6
because we see once again the weaknesses
on the light squares around the king
there is no black light squared bishop
that can help fight
along that color complex so the black
queen here had to drop back and in comes
the other bishop
yes and now there's a huge devastating
threat if you make a move like a6 which
you shouldn't make because it's on the
other side of the board in comes a
bishop to e6 check you don't want to
give your rook for a bishop but if you
move your king to either g7 or h8 the
problem is bishop e5 will in fact win
this black queen that's why bishops are
so powerful on an open board so fiona
instead of a6 a the move h5 was played
but that king is really really weak yeah
having to take drastic measures uh but
the bishop pair just continues
infiltrating their black position comes
into d7 attacking the rook the rooks get
traded but now white firmly in control
of the e-file the bishop pair
is working beautifully the position is
completely open just what the bishops
were hoping for black tries to get the
king into safety and in comes the next
white piece robert oh no you got to
bring all the pieces into the party rook
e6 is such a good move because queen f5
the bishop no longer attacks that square
right but if you play the move queen f5
i see the bishop i see the queen the
only thing in the way is the rook so a
move like rook e7 check would pick up
the queen and even the queen trade would
still be really good for white so
nothing that black can do really helps
out the knight on a5 not in the game at
all so queen f7 the queen backs up and
rook d6 i thought we liked that open
file fiona yeah but the rook is now
looking to free up the square for the
bishop once again that bishop has been
everywhere it's now looking to move
itself and for the work to infiltrate
along the seventh rank
just great peace movement by arjun he
understands the threats where the pieces
belong queen moves to e7 doesn't matter
bishop to e6 and now rook d7 is coming
so black ganguly he tried with rook
takes f4 please please please take me
back you then lose your rook on d6 that
would obviously be a tremendous blunder
so instead after rook takes f4 we see
the rook land on d7 and fiona it was a
matter of technique from here yeah and
now arjun is going to pocket some
material takes uh the queen on d7 he now
has a queen for a rook and a knight and
from here on out it actually ended
relatively fast with arjun just showing
his technique to convert the material
advantage
that's right he did not take his foot
off the pedal brings his bishop to c8
plays g4 he's going after this king and
there was really little that black could
do it's too little too late with that
knight it finally enters the action but
after takes on h5 the bishop comes to e6
yet another nice bishop move
yes very nice cutting out the blackrook
from the defense now the queen is
getting ready to join the game maybe via
f5 and the rook is just helpless so
ganguly tried to bring the king to g7
but in comes the next piece uh the pawn
from f4 is suddenly joining the game as
well
that's right you bring all your pieces
into the attack then it goes to f5 and
ganguly takes on e6 because he sees that
the checkmate is coming now the bishop
is defended on e6 the queen is free to
gobble up the pawn on h5 and then come
to g6 thanks to the f5 pawn or into the
f7 square thanks to the bishop so rookie
six pawn takes and now it's a queen for
two minor pieces takes some more stuff
queen to e8 and queen of d7 and he
resigns because his queen side is
collapsing and that is your round six
rapid recap honestly fiona just such a
wonderful demonstration of the power of
the bishops by argenti it seems like
he's invincible right now yeah i mean
such an incredible start to the
tournament for him i'm curious where he
can take it uh from here but right now
we're looking at the results from round
six in the master's groups we see see
there's still one game going in the
challenges in the background but in uh
the masters magnus carlsen won his game
against richard reports anish giri a big
win with the black pieces against
fabiano carrana and sergey karyakin won
his game against jordan fund for race
and uh let's look at the standings
robert
you may not see origen erguise's name
there right now but next year it seems
extremely likely that he will join the
pack he leads the challenger section the
winner of that tournament makes their
way into the masters 2023 but here and
now we see magnus carlsen mama jaroff
bitter gujarati all at four out of six i
don't know why i didn't say shakuriya i
said all the other first names but
either way it's a three-way tie and
fiona we can look all the way down to
eighth place because in each geary and
sixth sergey kayaking and eighth they
both won their games today yeah i mean
all of these players are still
contenders for the tournament victory
all within one point of the leaders and
there's still seven rounds uh to go
robert let's look at the pairings for
tomorrow one more time i already said
for me the three standout
pairings that i'm looking forward to a
prague against magnus a richard report
against mamedyarov and you're the
inventor race against fit it but there
will be action everywhere
and at first i was afraid for pragmata
in that theoretical battle against sam
shanklin but now i'm just incredibly
impressed so we'll see what he does
against magnus so that's going to be a
really fun matchup and the rest of them
are no less exciting you've referred to
your three favorite games
i'm going to be lazy and just say all
seven are highly anticipated from my
perspective so i really look forward to
tomorrow's action
unfortunately robert uh you will not be
here with us any longer than yeah uh
naraditsky will be taking over but will
be here at the same place at the same
time at 2 p.m central european uh time
that's 5 a.m pacific the day after that
will also be around around 8 and then on
january 24th is our next
wednesday so
robert uh it's been so much fun covering
this first half of the tournament
with you thank you so much for the
insights
for all the good times we had and well
i'll leave you close this one out
well i have to thank you first and
foremost because my job would not be
nearly as fun without you so fiona i
have to extend a really hearty thanks
because it really was a great time and i
know i give the chat a hard time
i know i do
but it's not really out of love but i
will express my gratitude to them as
well because the chess has seen such an
increase in viewership so many people
interested in the game and i just
really enjoy trying to help everybody
get a little bit better day by day if
that's what they're interested in if
they just want to watch the games and
hear the thoughts of
you and i as commentators then that's
also good enough so thank you to
everybody who's tuned in of course bick
as producer has been awesome and the
players they deserve really the most
thanks because without them we don't
have great games to cover and our time
is not nearly as enjoyable so fiona i'm
gone today is my last day but you will
have a better time because daniel
neroditsky he is absolutely a pleasure
we shall miss you but i'm sure we'll
have you back somewhere very soon robert
thank you so much thank you to all of
you for watching us i will see you
tomorrow i just want to say hi
bye bye it's early for all of us but
fabi you're looking fresh no thanks
danny
chad likes it man looking good
what about me
all right guys let's go run a show back
here we go
and fabi this video series was great by
the way people love it
really
do by the way again dude you're
you're just looking fresh man i love
your new haircut makes me good
hey there how's it going
[Music]
i don't even recognize myself
the whole new me
[Music]
hey phobia dan how's it going hey robert
hey man
you know i'm just trying out a few new
things here and there the day is
beautiful sun is out
cool
hey danny yeah
forgot to mention that haircut's looking
real fresh on you yeah thanks man
cool
appreciate it
serious
what does a guy guy do around you to get
noticed
what are you talking about
i
this seems a little out of line a little
uncalled for
you know you already can't spell chess
without him on board does he want
[Music]
you